wow great hello everybody is
Friday January 12th
2024 thank you thank
you welcome everybody it's our first
week back it's Friday it's Friday baby
and uh we are here it is after dark and
first I want to we are an hour late and
I am and I hate doing that and it's it
is my fault God and I you know I always
keep it 100 with you guys and I I don't
want to I frankly it's embarrassing but
I'll I'm going to say it because I have
to right you I mean the people deserve
to know I knew you were going to say it
yeah you knew it yeah of course it's not
that embarrassing no it's a little it's
a bit much at the top of the show but
they deserve an
answer let me get a sip of this coffee
first oh my God this morning I was up at
a good time I was on track to be on time
everything was going good
uhhuh no then I had the urge like people
do to uh use the restroom number two by
the way just to be
clear uh excuse the
vulgarity
um now some there's different types of
people in the world some people they can
control when they make that number too
me kind of for me that's not how it
works it's now it's like it's happening
now it's like I was thinking about when
you gave birth to Bruce yeah it felt
like that kind of where you're like it's
happening now
interesting so I kind of know what you
mean I kind of know understand pregnancy
yeah
totally congratulations probably it it
probably was even harder for me
because the kids were there the dogs was
was a hard so I'm sitting down and I've
got the sensation the feeling that
something's going to
happen but nothing is
happening nothing is
happening I wish that's what happened
Zach I think I know where this is
going I'm sorry it doesn't go much
further than that where did you think it
was yeah I'm very curious what you
thought well you know I worked for you
for almost what over 3 years now you I
clogged it I've never seen you in pants
before you wearing pants today you're
not wearing shorts oh interesting what
would have happened on that toilet
though I thought baby you your
pants oh my God at home and I didn't
change you changed that's what I'm
saying but I it was like a last minute
decision and you just threw on some
pants it's true okay I've good it's a
very educated guest based on who we're
talking about and the history
mhm I apologize no you're good you're
good
we love all opinions
here um I was so constipated and I've
never constipated you guys got to
understand right it's Falls
usually and just like Niagara Falls they
say at the perfect time of day there's a
perfect gold Shimmer off it so is true
of my
diarrhea right nice you they turn off
Niagara too maybe that's what's
happening don't actually have diarrhea
every time but you know what I'm talking
about the Niagara Falls golden the
Golden hour or whatever it's like a
special I didn't know about it but I can
visualize it well it's important for the
setting of The Story So let me pull it
up or maybe I'm thinking of Vernon Falls
actually and yosan Vernon Falls H yeah
the Vernon Falls golden hour
guys all right whatever I'm not finding
photos
but
um I was just the time was passing 10 20
and nothing's happening and I'm I'm
pushing and I'm pushing and nothing is
happening I've got like you even have a
poop stool where you put your feet up
yes I was using that does it help you
didn't help me then okay I'll tell you
what my legs were going so numb I had to
stand up and take a I know that feeling
I had to take a
walk
no did and then at this point it's
already like you
know 12:30 yep I'm walking around taking
a lap cuz my legs are tired and it's
12:30 it's horrible situation just
tragic aniy but I knew I didn't have a I
didn't have a choice it was like it was
now it had to be now you understand I do
but I was getting worried for you to to
sit and push for an hour no it felt
really unhealthy oh yeah I was trying to
tell him like stop try later in the day
like just don't do this I always hear
people saying you're not supposed to do
that but I've never had to do it before
so yeah I've been through all that I've
had lots of constipation in my life it
was like a um and I was like don't do
this this is exactly what you don't want
to do you know what it was it was like
one of those uh what do you call those
cute little critters that stand up in
the meadow right prairie dogs it is I
had a little prairie dog won't come out
kept he kept popping out just looking
around but the coast was not clear you
just got to like say okay go back in
it's not happening right now I say
turtle was sticking his head out of the
shell that's usually my analogy I go to
turtlenecking is I try I wanted to go
one
step I thought turtlenecking but then I
thought I wanted to
innovate PR prairie
dogging yeah but anyway by the time it
was about 1:00 I I'd say maybe 12:45 and
our drive here is like 50 minutes it was
a long one
today by the way our neighbor such an
douchebag
too they they Park in this way that it's
like how do I even explain it so we've
never had a psychotic neighbor I think
but we're experiencing one right now and
they
will park like exactly at the edge of
their property in on ours so that it
blocks us so it's really hard to get out
and they're doing it on purpose they
have a huge area there they have a ton
of free space before and they don't they
park at the edge and then it becomes
like super tight for us get hug front
yard with tons of parking and then they
go whatever anyone parks there who's
from our house or us they freak the
out oh my God and they go this is it's
public it's a public let's say I
have
I have a hairdresser or trainer come
they'll come for an hour they just park
on the street so sometimes they'll park
in front of their house but it's the
street I never and so they get mad they
scream at people I did I met them they
yell at linao tell me about that um yeah
just like what you guys are saying they
said they didn't want you guys or your
visitors parking there anymore Street
yeah yeah I'm like it's all public and
she's like well they have the spinny
cars and and whatnot and they're like
you guys always have visitors dude we
have and those people are come they come
for like an hour and they leave you know
that's what I said yeah welcome to
living in a neighborhood go to the
Prairie and go live in the on
the Range so now this is their new thing
they've been doing it every day they
Park in a way that almost blocks us that
we can't get
through on purpose yeah and I don't want
to go argue with them no them but
yeah I saw them for the first time
today well as we were leaving and it was
very difficult to leave yeah
and they wouldn't even look at me
cowards oh cowards who yelled at you
Lena was the guy or the lady the lady G
it's by the way it's an old dude with a
trophy wife situation mhm nice it's the
lady do you think she's the instigator
or maybe they maybe they're aligned I
think they're aligned somehow I think
they have they share the opinion that
they don't want you parking there but
also they were arguing a lot last time
like I can hear them they were fighting
each
other this is they're lashing out the
pain Paradise they didn't look happy
when I saw them I think they were just
got done yelling at somebody the call is
coming from inside so this isn't about
you guys wen't they yelling at somebody
actually the mail lady as we were
leaving she was saying I can't get
through to deliver mail because these
and I was like can you tell
them something because they're doing
this on purpose so she went to talk to
them oh you narked on them I did okay I
well I tell I told them lady can you go
say something to them cuz I'm
scared so she was like yes I'm going to
go talk to them right now so she they
were arguing with the male lady when we
came out wow wow a lot of pain over
there but yeah at any rate whatever I
don't care about them
um but obviously they're not happy at
home yeah yeah so if he ever yells at me
I'll be like work on your wife or work
on your marriage bro work on your
marriage just get super nasty
the most
insulting yeah for it anyway yeah I
dropped let's see I dropped my linoln
logs okay and
um built a cabin
congratulations and uh we hit the road
but that was it and I I apologize for
that really was I don't I don't
understand you know I've been doing so
much fiber m hitting these uh Metamucil
drinks like crazy I guess I do it with
every
meal chug a glass of yesterday we ate
pizza and I think Pizza is not good but
I had metam Musa with it yeah Pizza is
actually very nutritious it's actually
very
nutricious
okay so that's what it is but I'm sorry
guys I'm
sorry all right uh there's a somebody's
trying to call in what's the deal uh
yeah somebody in the zoom room named uh
tough cookie
69 oh are you kidding me oh oh my God
you're tough cookie
69 hey man what's going on how are you
how are you guys you look so both of you
look beautiful hila you look amazing
Ethan I am digging your guys hats I
don't know what's going on here but you
guys look cool thanks what's going on
how are you both what's going on with
you oh nothing can we stop with the
clown stuff come on yeah let's get
serious now new year new me it's a new
year Oliver's being nice it's
2024 I'm not going to return the
compliment cuz I don't think you look
that good but that's but I'm just being
honest I'm being honest like the shirt
though yeah the shirt is awesome I was
talking about the hair how cool the hair
yeah I stopped using shampoo so it's a
little rough like the mustache though is
that painted on yeah I painted it on
before hard to tell it looks like
mascara Maybe yeah well it's a bunch of
those fake
eyelashes all right so what's going on
did you let me guess let me guess Oliver
no no I just want let me guess why
you're calling in well I just can I
guess for one I'm guessing it's not to
sell Bibles at all oft tree.com no come
on I'm done with that new year new me
man see you would call you wouldn't call
in this show just a promo you would call
in to say hi in the new year for sure
for sure and I want to say I love that
zipper I mean that thing is crazy yeah
show it off Ela let me see that thing
that is insane that's on Teddy that's on
Teddy fresh.com right now wow I love
that I want to just check in see how my
godsons are how's Michael and
Theodore who's
Michael Michael the younger one okay we
should name the new baby Michael maybe
oh oh we can't figure out name the baby
oh yeah Edward right what's the what's
the new one's name do you have name to
suggest I was thinking Oliver would be
cool just kind of
celebratory yeah what else that seems
nice actually Oliver maybe Oliver
Jupiter um Jupiter wait we actually I
actually know what Jupiter through Ian
yeah I that's the only Jupiter do you
know a Jupiter yeah Oliver Jupiter That
was supposed to be my name and what
happened they just were like this I
don't know my mom didn't go with it her
best friend had a dream that uh before I
was born the day before I was born the
my name would be Oliver Jupiter and I
guess my mom didn't like it oh so she
was just planning on it for one day
though so it didn't seem like it was
that serious of a
commitment I guess not but yeah I mean
I'm not you know I'm not one to ask for
favors but um of course not all right
well thanks for checking in
buddy goad appreciate it always nice to
hear from you oliv thanks you can hang
out no I just you can hang up I got into
a little bit of a bind can we
than thanks for talk thanks for
calling all right that was so nice of
him just to call in and check up on us
wait where did he go I we we ended the
call I hung up he said hung up thought
it seemed like it kind of had reached
this natural conclusion there yeah I
like 2024 Oliver yeah he's uh he's
changed actually I think he's really
changed yeah that's exciting short and
sweet short but very sweet there's
somebody new in the waiting room all
Oliver Jupiter you think that this is
your son from the future I don't know
Oliver Jupiter you don't know an Oliver
Jupiter who's Oliver called bandom oh
wait that's that's just Oliver again oh
I thought we were done talking Oliver
his name wasn't Oliver jup I'm sorry you
guys I maybe we started off on the wrong
foot no I thought I we had a great combo
man good talk you guys I know I don't
I'm not one to ever ask for favors or
anything all right cool well that's
great then because I love that about you
all right we'll see you later buddy I
hav no I real quick just bear with me
here so as you guys know I love to
gamble and um I so I had a little bit of
a dilemma where I kind of owe some money
to my uncle um it's not a lot of money
but I just I was wondering if maybe you
guys could spot me maybe all right
Oliver treat thanks for calling in buddy
wait please please please catching up
with
you you guys all right if you want to do
money I could take something maybe you
know since I was the first male model
Oliver tree everybody he's doing really
good 2024 is treating him
[Music]
well y um always cool to hear from him
yeah hope he's doing
good he had a good run in Vegas it
sounds like lucky yeah I need the ducky
is really trying to chew on some cables
speaking of Vegas we got to plan our
trip guys
yeah does anyone have an opinion about
when that should take place the exact
date and the hotel what you doing
tonight I need it's Friday baby I guess
I'll call my parents and see if they can
watch you guys have a meeting by the way
with a teddy fresh model there's a Teddy
fresh M that's calling in no I don't
usually meet with the models you you
don't handle that somebody on the team
handles that I talk to them but wait
that's not wait Oliver what happened we
keep getting we keep getting connected I
think maybe I'm I have a bad connection
um but I just wanted to say do you guys
remember when I did that whole modeling
campaign for Tedy
fresh oh all that are you talking about
when you photoshopped that
billboard you guys let's be real I
remember no I remember we had a good
time on the website I'm pretty sure we
could pull it up but um no I was the
first Teddy fresh model yeah I feel like
I don't know if I would call it a model
was like more of a a gifting situation
where we SE a lot of people an
influencer like yourself I'm not really
much of an influencer but uh I did kind
of put you guys on the map um I don't
want to extend myself and say too much
but I feel like it would be fair to just
you even just a small you know what do
you want 5% maybe of Teddy fresh because
you had a bad gambling what does that
have to do with you want you want equity
in my business cuz you had a bad
gambling weekend what does does even
make sense if you want if you're asking
for Equity that means you don't even
going to make it fine I would take
Equity I don't I don't see what that's
what 5% is you know what Equity
means he take that 5% yeah I what about
2.5% it's just it's your buddy over but
that's not GNA put money in your pocket
right now you know that right but I
could sell it I could probably sell it
for a lot 1% all I'm asking you 1% of
Teddy fr how's that going to help you
how much money do you owe I it's not a
lot it's it's like just shy of
250,000
50,000 all right don't you have a label
or some it's always giving you
label they're basically gonna drop me if
I can't get the money together because I
can't afford to record more stuff so in
order for me to make the next album if I
was going to make one by theia and I
probably won't but I can't look at I put
a
loan there's a lean on my parents house
and maybe you could do one one music
video shot on the
phone guys that's true El I mean real
Innovation comes they say that uh
necessity is the mother of uh invention
they say that right somebody says that
yeah somewh and so um there's been you
hold on listen this is important Oliver
I'm giving you I'm giving you good
advice you know Old Dirty Bastard
perform he recorded some really good
music and prison on a cell phone and
those are some of the iconic songs today
I don't know about prison that's a
little early my point is you have even
more you're even you're better off than
he is because you're not in prison you
have like and also you have a modern day
phone well I I don't have theone what's
off the screen there why do you keep
going off the screen I don't I'm sorry
but I are you huffing something bro what
is
Jesus I'm not well
I've been pretty sick so sorry I'm just
blowing my nose here all right buddy no
just listen level with me here we'll
draft the papers okay no no okay wait
one sec Oliver one sec uh did you guys
put in your Boba order by the
way guys did you guys all get boba just
one second Oliver Oliver no now was
really not the time guys did you order
already Oliver do you like B uh did you
I'm not a fan of B not a I didn't get it
I didn't get the Boba didn't get the
oh no what flavor did you want today no
I didn't want you did not at all to I
got one without Boba yeah you get no
Boba today I'm trying something a
littlea call I am anti Boba I'm against
the Boba movie what if we open a Boba
place but they we don't have Boba we
call it
NOAA just drinks we just have have tons
of people in there for no reason very LA
to
am I still on is this thing still on
yeah yeah it's on it's on this guy stop
talking jeez if you could hold off for a
second well no I'm trying to say
something um right I want you're
interrupting go ahead no I'm not
interrupting I just feel like I you know
how much money I've made you with all
these podcast episodes and these how
many tickets have I sold you your show
you want talk about who made who is
there even is there even such thing as a
Oliver tree fan like I don't even know
if that's a real thing no here's the
thing bro we tried to do a US tour and
the tickets are selling really bad and I
I mean I didn't want to ask you but
maybe maybe you could just promote
that so you're having a US tour right
now yeah it starts tomorrow oh oh gosh
that's not a lot of time well that's
very last minute to start promoting we
can try I know that's what I'm saying
and that's why things have been so South
because I've been traveling and I just
went across all seven continents like I
promised you I would here well yeah I
mean I wasn't I didn't I don't care for
the record wasn't like when was that
promise you didn't
promise last time I gave a show if you
listen to anything I say okay let's
promote it let's do it let's here's on
sale this week's this week's s is that
his website olivetree.com yeah this is
his website new Bible studies promotion
this is a good deal actually dude it
used to be 300 and now
was9 Ean stop the new daily Study Bible
oh
for 50 years and for millions of readers
the daily Study Bible commentaries have
been the ideal help for both devotional
and serious Bible study 50 years wait
when did you start this project 50 years
of greatness I don't sell
Bible what are you talk well yeah it's
not a Bible it's a study it's a study
Bible this wasn't in the uh this wasn't
in the Darman video oh you do like audio
books is that it cuz there I see this I
do audio books on the side but that's
nothing to do with the Bible
I did do a graphic novel I remember I
gave you guys the sign copy and you hate
it you me to read it here's marriage and
family they better be any homophobic
in here bro no no no it's not can
you sign one of these for us the
marriage and
family I could
technically building a Godly home volume
one that's a banger can you sign that
for I see a lot of people saying they
they love what they're seeing and
they're checking out already oh they see
sales flowing yeah the tour the US tour
that starts tomorrow do do you get a
ticket along with the Bible purchase
like is there's no Bible I think you
have the wrong
link wrong link let's see what site are
you on congratulations this is
olivetree.com this is your literally
your name ol tree with the r dude oh
congratulations how many times do I have
to say this why the is this on your
website Oliver hold on Oliver hold on
the truth about samesex marriage things
you need to know about what's really at
stake what that's up bro that's
actually sick I don't I don't have
anything to do with that we can't be
associated with anything like that
Oliver May 2009 G revealed that 57% of
Americans oppose same-sex marriage and
certainly Teddy fresh cannot be
Associated I'm not one of those people
Ethan do not put those words in my mouth
oh my God I think that I think that this
might actually I I I'm picking up from
him that this might not be his website
really it's not the site thank D
Jesus it is his name I think the problem
is that his has music in it I think it's
Olive Tree music.com it's Oliver with
the r is it with a hard R I got you hold
on Olive Tree Music a soft R it's a soft
okay hold up oh here Oliver tree
official website this is it right is
that it God damn it is that him wait
wait wait no I think that's him you yeah
I think that's you alone and yeah that's
it that's that's the oh so it's
olivertree music.com olivertree music
that's kind of a long uh URL what is
wrong with you man you doctor or
something bro sick I'm pretty sick are
you sure you can perform like
that I can I just I don't have money to
go to the hospital right now I'm not
comfortable selling tickets if you're
that sick no Ethan Ethan I just don't
think it's fair to put the audience out
like that you're gonna put on a show
tomorrow dude you're on life support
brother no I'm not I'm not better I'm
better now I'm fine all right so what
you have a show tomorrow in
Chicago and I clicked to look to buy
tickets and look at this I got a
hackers warning where's the sonar beep
coming from all right Ticket Master you
work with them
coward what why do you work with Ticket
Master bro I have nothing to do with it
I don't even know oh this Chicago's
about to sell out man there's only like
a couple hundred tickets left there
5,000 people I want you to be there
maybe you is it really 5,000 wow yeah
with only a couple hundred tickets left
yeah why are we helping you promote it
sounds like you're doing F man some of
the other shows are doing bad
brother wait hold the phone bro that's
you should be shouting me out at your
damn shows what is this I do shout you
out every night yeah you go Ethan
CL you go Ethan kin I didn't
even do that that was your fans who
started the chance I had nothing to do
with that here what's this one
Toronto that one sold out thought you
were banned from sold out what wait
that's sold out no issues selling
tickets what is why you why why did you
dude listen wait can you um can you
shout out Teddy fresh I wanted the shows
sounds like a big opportunity on the
stage whatever you want man we could
sell Teddy fresh at the merch
booth just a shout out just a shout out
sorry I could do whatever you want dude
all right say say at the beginning of
the show say hi I'm Oliver tree go to
Teddy fresh.com new collection is out
now thank you hi at the show Oliver tree
here Kenny fresh is now online yes and
say it's my favorite brand and the deals
are crazy say that my favorite brand and
they got these new freaking deals that
are crazy Ethan please man I need aren't
I doing it now what more do you want
from me like we're doing I'm literally
doing maybe you could read off some of
the dates I don't
know it's a lot of dates it's a lot of
dates it's like anytime between now and
any date in
particular oh can you guys come to the
LA show maybe on stage you have two
shows in different locations oh yeah
yeah I forgot to tell you I'm a DJ Now
hey the uh the Boba came guys yeah check
it
out which one did you get please stop
stop
uh what did you guys like the milk tea
one there let me just put you on hold
for a second guys are we still why does
he need help why is he asking us to I
don't know I muted him
for okay he's doing two La shows in two
different
Arenas right sounds like he's doing
really well yeah what's the problem you
know um why is he selling Bibles he's
doing really good you know what he did
the other day he actually asked me if I
wanted to go like if we wanted to go to
that La show yeah and um I said yeah
sure there's like there's about like
there's like 11 or 12 of us is that cool
and he's like yeah I'll I'll give you a
hookup with um some VIP
tickets
MH is that what happened last time no
like like you have to buy the VIP
tickets you're trying to sell us tickets
yeah how many seats is at the Hollywood
padium can anyone hear me oh yeah yeah I
just unmuted you guys I want to make a
deal Ethan Kila I want to offer you the
deal of a lifetime yeah 4,000 huh okay
well technically speaking last time we
sold out 5,000 this one will sell out in
the next couple days but what I will say
is this if you guys are open to selling
tickets to your fans I can give you a
percentage of a commission on each
ticket you sell and let's just say you
had friends like let's say Dan for
example one to buy tickets and sell
tickets as well he could sell tickets
and you could make a percentage off his
ticket so sounds a lot like what Austin
MC bro's been trying to do huh wait
you're actually doing a DJ set holy
bro come on man I'm a DJ
now dude you're you're charging 35 bucks
for that bro this set is gonna be
the greatest DJ set of all time please
35 bucks 35 that's like that's like
standup mic rate let me that's like open
mic night let me say this this DJ said
is an audio visual experience that's an
hour and a half super set I've worked on
it for the last year and a half it's my
heart and soul has put pushing forward
the idea of DJing thank you what do you
say about this deal I think we could
sell tickets on your guy site to your to
make a percentage all right somebody in
the chat said La changed you Oliver no I
didn't even I don't even live in LA I
don't live anywhere
right maybe that's the problem bro maybe
it's time to start getting your feet on
the ground getting down to earth I know
and that's why I'm trying to get the
house
back no no wait don't guys tree if you
guys want tickets to USA tour go to
olivetree.com Olive Tree Music guys
there's going to be so
much going to meet your wife your
husband your significant other please
come to this
show I want you there we'll see you
there buddy Ethan come to the show the
whole free tickets I'm giving them out
like hot cak
please yeah I think he just more than
anything doesn't want to see all those
empty seats cuz it's it feels really bad
like as a performer I can that's my fear
that's why I don't want to go too big
right you can only imagine how bad that
would feel too yeah I think he might
just have a drug
problem oh he's such a such a good boy
ducky a ducky such a good boy you are so
good he went on the pead well done well
done
sir he's a potty training Champion he's
learning everything so fast
congratulations all right can we do our
show I mean what the hell dude every
time okay oh my God that's how I feel
not going to let him derail
the the call again or the show
again um real quick since we're at the
top of the show here technically even
though like the middle uh new Teddy
fresh collection is out now check out
the big zip that's what ela's wearing
and ab's wearing it too the zipper is
enormous is this inspired by my jacket I
used to own when I met Ethan he used to
have a puffer jacket that had a gigantic
zipper I think it was this and it was so
funny like it was just the puffer plain
Navy puffer totally regular but a giant
zipper and and frankly as someone that's
owned a giant zipper item for it is so
funny everybody loves
it it it really is a really fun
conversation starter they go yo you're
got a big zipper buddy and you're like
hey it's me big zipper guy it's big zip
it's your boy big zip call me they
called me big zip did they yeah makes a
nice noise sick dude go ahead ducky s s
like Lego sound oddly
satisfying so that's the big zip the big
zip DD doah andah dude this collection
we had fun with like um playing with
scale and so just making like stuff
really big or really small this is a
print of a desktop a messy desktop messy
desktop now you can wear your messy
desktop it's not even just on your
computer where you feel anxious now you
can wear it and feel anxious right this
sweater is
beautiful yeah thank you anyone wearing
that
one this Dan you're wearing that one
right or what I'm wearer version of
it extremely cozy why is this sweater so
cozy what's going on it's really cozy
right it's like stupidly though I think
it's just Superior um it like feels so
nice Superior um Fabrics I mean whenever
we work on stuff like that we pick the
yarn and we have all kinds of yarn
options to go with and
so we have our
favorites this shirt too there's like
it's a really smooth feeling yarn that I
really like
M by the way I love this silouette it's
like a hooded sweater I used to have
which is also one you used to really a
great a great silhouette this is one
that loves wearing let's go this is all
of our logos that we've worked on over
the years yeah I kind of nerded out on
this one I got both colors cuz I thought
I remember a lot of these like uh back
back in the day we were trying to nail
down the the logo for so long you
know and just making so many versions of
them which one is the first is it the
top left one the first one is not here
actually it's the handdrawn one that's
it's like um It's a combination of the
top left and the top right not top top
right but with the teddy fresh yeah it's
very cool um
um this is oh giant
pocket it's a giant pocket holy all
your groceries in it every one of them
uh what else we got this is what I'm
wearing it's medium by the way oh
wow
wow nice congratulations
congratulations yeah
uh yeah yeah yeah and you guys want to
show up what are you guys wearing out in
the uh one you just Olia and Lena are
wearing the the dress Lena and I are
sisters today twinning you're twinning
oh do we love it we do we love it
it's so cute especially the zipper pole
it's a little it's in the outline of a
bear
mhm the details are just and never
stopping for this shirt we made the bear
super big the bear patch I love the
sizing Big Bear p
anyways lots of fun stuff go to Teddy
fresh.com for the new collection this
one's crazy and
awesome nine more
images I'll just quickly go through them
excuse me Teddy fresh.com all right
thanks we don't have a sponsor today so
you guys are getting off
[Applause]
easy
um excuse me
goddamn
so let's see we've got a ton of stories
we're still catching up although there's
a new one that's happening right now Ace
family divorce
mhm I can't believe it I thought they
were the perfect family I'm crushed yeah
crushed never have I would have never
guessed that the the relationship wasn't
perfectly healthy my blood
boiling foreclosing on a house can put a
lot of strain on a relationship I
imagine yeah also having a husband that
is serially cheating on you is is can be
a tremendous strain on
a yeah sometimes that's what they say
yeah yeah constantly dming uh in uh only
fans models trying to sign them up look
at this so first let's look at the
announcements and then Austin's been
dming only fans models trying to recruit
them the best life possible and now
we've had
another person reached out so we had two
separate people reach out to show us
receipts uhhuh it's very interesting
apparently this is like a thing that's
happening tons of influencers men and
women mostly men are messaging girls I
think these these companies agencies
whatever they're
paying
influencers to DM people and recruit
them interesting how sick
it is it's totally behind the scenes and
then what you see when I'll show pull it
up is they're all the same they're copy
pasting the same
message what so what I think is
happening is Austin is probably for him
to debase himself that
low a man with
children uh he's got to be earning like
a lifetime percentage or something
mhm and he also has like been unfaithful
right rumor has it lots of rumors lots
of rumors M yeah anyway here is
um dude we got that Ace family framed
photo in the bathroom what do we do with
that it's so messed up we honor them
what are you talking about grab it
yeah well here I actually have this oh
that's yeah there it is I sent in our
group chat yesterday a picture of it cuz
I was just so devastated by the news CU
I cry my eyes out in the bathroom right
now so true so and
cam sent
this oh no cam you did him there daddy
wasn't there oh no I think we do need to
actually
modify this here it is oh it's quite big
I forgot how big it is oh
yeah and this is what we got at Ace Fest
we had it signed mhm this is
authenticated real signed this is when
the family was still together yep and so
the value on this has got to be going up
like by the
minute now what we need to do is get a
signed poster from each parent
individually so that we can have
different eras represented like when
they're together and they're separated
one from each
yeah but of course I'm joking but the
kids lose the kids lose and they've been
losing
unfortunately and I'm sure they saved
lots of money for their college funds I
hope so from using their kids for money
what why you laughing you don't think
they save money for the college fund you
don't think they have a fat S&P 500
investment account for them uhuh what do
you think since their entire brand was
built around exploiting their children
that they would have set aside some
percentage of that money if they love
them I really hope so that's maybe not
that the silver lining of all this is I
hope it means two Ace fests now oh does
this mean there
oh dude that's a good point competing
Ace Fest yo does this mean there's not
going to be another Ace Fest oh that
would be tragic no it's like it's like
Christmas you get two Christmases two
Hanukkah two birthdays two Ace fests oh
man all right so here's Katherine she
put out a
post pretty boring honestly like I read
this I was like whatever just tell me
what actually happened nobody you know
what I mean like look get a load of
this as I start this New Year I will
challenge myself in ways that I have
never done
before 2024 will be my year of
transformative change and with this
taking place one of the steps of my
journey is a difficult decision to leave
my marriage so she's making it sound
like she left his ass yeah she left his
cheating scheming that's what I when I
read that ass dude's not even an earner
anymore he's in DM trying to earn
commission from actual workers
yep we have mutually agreed uh girl you
can't walk that back you can't go to
mutually agreed to divorce and will part
amicably our paths as couples have
shifted yada yada yada she feel she says
I'm heartbroken but I also feel
liberated that's a jab did she post
first
[Music]
yeah I am goofing but divorce is really
horrible it is horrible especially when
there's kids involved but I me have
three little kids who gets custody of
the jet ski ick Clark ass I'm sure
they'll they'll they'll dude I'm sure
their divorce uh talks will be really
fun with the war and stuff although who
knows maybe it's am maybe he gets to
keep all the of commissions and she stop
gets full custody of the
kids oh
god um blah blah blah yada yada our main
priority will be to stay United as
parents y y y and Austin you're my best
friend and that will never change yeah
dude I'm not buying it
a million likes though people really
with these people man
yeah uh probably not the best time to
say this but it's about damn time happy
for you you deserve loyalty so I guess
everybody knows he's like a Serial
cheater yeah it's pretty open About Time
Katherine you deserve way better I just
need a little excitement in my life I
know man but you got to find other ways
to do that because when you cheat on
your wife you also cheat on your kids
when they're young kids man you do
you're doing it to your whole family I
would never do anything to hurt them
ever okay
well I hope that's true why is everyone
hating on Austin in here what the hell
where have you
been some people might just be this man
hasn't open YouTube in a decade all
right idiot here comments s l juicier
I'm going to go to his next yeah all
right this man hasn't opened uh YouTube
since their first St
yeah he was out at charity raising event
oh my God congratulations girl you can
do so much better than him he's been
weighing you down for years dude the the
comments are wild though this is like a
celebration because I think with him I
read that it's just been it's been said
so many times by many people that he's a
cheater yeah and she's probably had to
deal with that every single time you
know somebody says it and you know what
I'm assuming but she's probably like
always forgiving him trying to make it
work for the family and his dumb ass
keeps doing it of course I'm this is all
I don't know anything yeah we don't know
anything about them but I'm for sure
right
yeah um here's Austin's post let's
compare
it hers had a million his oh his only
has 650,000 which is a lot but Catherine
Catherine is the bread winner here uhhuh
Austin
who if I were going to drop a like I
would drop it on Catherine it's a lot by
the way I think I support Catherine yeah
I'm with her should I like it maybe
we'll like it you can like it I'm cool
with that thank you like it girl thank
you girl why this I mean if you're going
to cheat on your wife with three young
children yeah I'm I'm immediately
sighing with the wife obviously why this
photo this is the divorce
photo they sky jumped they
skydived she's like you
know the parachute didn't open on our
marriage I don't know read the caption
and it will all make sense for this new
year I'll be taking a leap of faith
there you
[Music]
go he trusted that parachute God yeah
that's corny you bro it's a little corny
yeah I've made the hardest decision of
my life the decision to close the book
of my marriage so he's trying to say he
left her yes which is why I was waiting
for you to read this one and that's why
I asked if she posted first because
right it's like oh you're going to say
that you did so I'm going to say the
same thing why is his his profile
picture is just his name like Austin
he's a brand that's actually the worst
cuz like who the it's
Austin I wonder what Katherine will do
now I'm curious and I I don't think
he'll do anything I think he's just
like nobody likes you bro
um does she not have some like Beauty
line or
something wait hold on wasn't there even
like Scandal around it something yeah
she was like yeah there was a whole
Beauty Scandal where like her ex partner
was suing her yep yeah something like
that skin care brand she did like a Hos
takeover or something there's a couple
things with her too yeah she has her
fair that that said that is my guess is
that that's where her pivot will be
buding Beauty gross Jordan we have
mutually agreed to divorce that's this
basically the same thing we both
understand that we want to be parents
and blah blah blah and yada yada yada
okay oh I'm seeing in the chat that this
photo is from when he
proposed oh that's that's sad that's
kind of that's kind of sad yeah
hey that's really sad bro why would you
his ass got dumped yeah to make her feel
bad or something he he for sure got
dumped because this photo is way too
sentimental
right and what what was her photo again
it was just the message I think it was
just a message right she didn't even
post it's a good move she it's her she
left him definitely no question about it
good for he was for sure crying when he
posted this I saw people say it's wild
to phrase your divorce as like a New
Year resolution yeah new year new year
like this year right my resolution is to
be single and ready coconut say you're
divorced
yeah I don't know but I mean listen I I
wish the best for their family for their
kids but uh this was this is the sad
part now here's the funny and really
wait you missed the comments on that oh
right right right right under I got a
comment on it that got like 3,000 likes
you did oh in the mix all
right let's see here wamp wamp how' you
fumble a 10 oh so she's she's got
suitors eh
people are lining
up talking about divorce like a New
Year's resolution is crazy
congratulations in other words he's
saying he's for the streets uh gave her
hella kids for what yeah never did I
think I would see a post about them
divorcing I'm in denial right now oh
that person is just sad they're just
devastated sorry you didn't see this
coming M you know I thought they might
be like having thick as thieves kind of
thing you know what I mean like they're
in it together I think they definitely
Port they portrayed themselves like that
but yeah their last YouTube video which
was it was like 7 months ago but in it
they were talking about them on planning
their wedding and they wanted it to be
so extravagant like The Royal Wedding
they were explaining uh so I have a
theory about people that do huge
weddings it's always it will never work
yep people who do huge extravagant
weddings are Mega overcompensating and
that never works cuz the
expectation from the beginning is crazy
like you need your wedding to be um
Buckingham Palace like that's your
expectation you want to start there and
then come from Buckingham Palace where
everybody is there and you've got like
elephants like fresh picked flowers you
know what I mean so over the top
and then the next day you just go
home and then you got to live your life
right yep yeah I don't see it at our
wedding I have horror stories but when I
heard the prices of flowers I'm like
that I was like I'll put my own
flowers she's like what do you I was
like I'll get my own flowers flowers are
expensive as it was I was like
that I'm broke we got twigs and we put
lights around them and it was like a
Winter Wonderland theme that's fire
though I bet it look good if you did it
it look good it look good Lena it did
yeah I liked it we saved uh 18,000 I
think it was a crazy amount 18,000 yeah
that's insane $200 in my bank account
but in Dearborne you pay for the
weddings after the wedding same in
Israel like Israel oh nice we're the
same so you guys get um cash as gifts to
okay same people give you cash
gifts and then you you bank on that
basically paying for the wedding yeah
that's what we're used to too I didn't
know that was a thing until we moved
here that people don't usually gift
money for weddings I know was very weird
to me we psycho we made great money cuz
I'm I'm the first boy in the family and
extended family to get married the only
boy older than me is cousin Tim and
unfortunately he's he's never getting
married wait and so so it was a big
moment for everybody so you cleaned up
yeah we cleaned up we had enough to put
down payment on a house yeah yeah get a
car for you guys nice that's let that be
a lesson to people watching at home
that's how you get ahead mhm I mean why
should a why should a young couple
that's no what I mean what I mean by
that no I know what you mean cuz we've
talked about it why should a young
couple that is just about to start their
life spend ridiculous amounts of money
on like flowers and cake and all that
stuff instead of like saving that money
dumbest way to start toward their future
together dumbest let's you know what
would be perfect for our marriage and
our future family getting into a bunch
of debt right for nothing for one party
mhm or you spending all your money on a
ring is another thing that I don't like
the ring thing's
nuts you have a nice what what was your
budget on the ring or I you don't have
to answer that the first no the first
ring I got her was fake uh I mean it was
real it was my mom's wedding ring um but
my parents were divorced and the my mom
lost the diamond years ago but it was a
big ass Diamond so I couldn't pay to put
one in there so I put a fake one in
there hell yeah and uh yeah did you know
it was fake Lena yes she
knew are you muted you're you're muted
that's awesome you're
muted she's you're
muted yeah sorry I did know because it
you can hear it rattling like when I
hand you guys never talked about it but
you just knew cuz it oh I mean no we did
talk about it after I was like don't get
too excited though it's fake but uh we
had an engagement which is like a mini
wedding and I bought we made like I
think it was like uh 17K off of that and
then I got her ring with that which she
said she didn't need a real but I was
like no you deserve a real one I felt so
bad cuz yeah everyone in our hometown is
so materialistic but Lena didn't care so
let me see that thing let me see that
rock girl oh the one I have now yeah
let's go let's see that rock yeah damn
look all right all right everything
shiny as a mother I've never actually
bought youa I don't think I've ever
bought you nice jewelry no which I think
we B don't want the thing is Ela she
know if she wants to buy a nice thing
for herself she'll do it mhm that's kind
of how it is with both of us mhm not
waiting for ELA to buy me something but
I think the most what do we spend on the
ring I got you like 250 mhm something
yeah you know it's what it
is congratulations I love it though it's
a it's like a gold ring with a ruby a
pink Ruby mhm beautiful but you don't
have I don't think do you have any
diamonds I don't I'm an anti- Diamond
person
blood I shouldn't say blood diamond I
know mean that that I'm sure that one is
humanely that one was super Humane yes
yeah well even the lab ones are
expensive the lab ones are expensive
yeah they're like half the price which
you expect it to
be more cheap if it's not a real diamond
but good for you guys yeah we some
people in chat are saying they thought
we had a big wedding we did have a big
wedding but it could have been like five
times the price right it's not just
about the size it's not just the size of
like how many people come but it's there
so many like yeah there's so many
decisions you end up having to make and
everything is like oh do you want to
spend another
$10,000 or you could a fancy envelope
yeah like that it's all about the
family showing off and at least in AR
case yeah and so my mother-in-law who's
the sweetest lady in the world like she
got so annoyed of us she jumped out of
the car at a red light like why cuz you
guys were doing it so cheap yeah because
we're because we were going back well
Lena and her were going back and forth
so much
and then she got out the rest she's like
all right whatever I can't deal with
this and she's like I'm going to walk
home and I'm was like pulling her in
back in the car wait you and Lena
arguing or no her and her mom oh you
were arguing with your mom okay and you
wanted to go cheap and she wanted to
spend not necessarily cheap but I just
wanted things like the way we wanted to
do them for I think what we had just
left the banquet and we were discussing
like the menu for example and I didn't
want like every single dish they offer
and she's like no like you have to have
all it's exactly like us your dad my dad
was like no you have to get the best
meal option you have to tell tell them
what the lady told you L I was like are
you paying for it are you paying for it
guess what no no so I was telling the
bankr manager like that's how I want to
do it and and then she just like looked
over me and she talked to my mom she
like don't worry like she doesn't know
we'll we'll we'll do oh my God she put
her hand up and and like leena's face
she like I she's like I'm literally I'm
not even listening to you yeah B and I
was like this oh my God so much
for your wedding day that's why tensions
are a little built up on the ride
home did she get back in the car or did
she walk home oh I didn't I didn't let
her go yeah if he was grabbing her hand
which I I wasn't supposed to be touching
her hand because islamically she's not
my mother-in-law yet you're not if she's
wearing a scarf you're not supposed to
yeah uh let's
see I saw this person says saw this
coming I feel she's become very
spiritual and is trying to find herself
okay Cath aine's found
God she found inner peace and and
meaning in life since she left Austin
here's a cool comment my husband and I
make really good money and had a 5k
wedding with 10 guests and I have $1,000
ring and we bought a $1 million home
with the money we saved nice which is
amazing dude $5,000's a lot that's a lot
of money already like in the wedding
world that's practically nothing yeah
know yeah but like dude I could throw a
a good ass party for $5,000 like in the
backyard M $5,000 you know what I mean
5,000 that's a big ass budget for a
party hell yeah I wonder if he's
deleting comments by the way because
there was a lot of them about Michael B
Jordan wait what about Michael V Jordan
CU she used to date uh I mean he used to
date Katherine yeah before them yeah
before them and they've always kind of
held that over him whoa that's a gnarly
ex-boyfriend how do you live up to that
I know that that's that's like the worst
ex-boyfriend you could ever have well i'
I've always kind of had the theory that
a lot of the stuff Austin does is to
compensate for that like the whole
basketball game cuz he was a basketball
player like he wants to act like he has
that same fame maybe they'll come back
together is Michael be I think he's is
he married we're gonna have to work on
that I don't know they were always in
love they just the past didn't CR
right
that's
nuts who is it that she was dating
Michael B Jordan he's the guy from The
Wire the the scrawny kid from The Wire
that grew up and got all jacked
yeah everybody everybody loves him
now oh right and Austin did the boxing
thing was that was heting right right
right yeah oh weird this was kind of
yeah I found your comment AB I'll never
recover from this
bro rip neither will he yeah so but
anyway so that's the sad part but here's
the funny part and if you're feeling bad
for Austin don't worry this will make
you not feel bad for him at all
um so we talked about it on
Wednesday that Austin had sent here's
the one we shared
actually Austin had sent this uh person
on only fans it's the second
photo in this
album oh okay so th this is the girl who
this is the initial one yeah the one
that we talked about do we know her or
no no it was posted on our
subreddit so this this uh lady Laura
Lux I guess posted this DM on Twitter
didn't this guy have his for house
foreclosed on she said so he says my bad
for random DM are you signed to an
agency so this is the same message as we
saw before with the my bad so hold on
I'm so anyway she says I think agencies
are predatory scams run by corny men who
think they can involve themselves in
women's business you go girl so then we
had um little lyanna she's a fan we
talked about her uh previous episode but
she sent me this so little Lanna who's
also an she's an only she does only fans
yes okay um so he sent
her an identical DM and he even said my
strategy casual like he keeps you have a
typo in the first definitely word yes
it's exactly like you said I think my
bad he's like I don't really care that's
kind of psychotic my bad for the random
DM he said a close friend of
mine a close friend of your
what him and his lady run an agency and
they are wondering if you were signed
yet and then she asked are you involved
in the agency at all and then he said I
help them behind the
scenes they only work with a very select
group would love to connect you so you
can hear them out on what they could do
for you this sounds like sex trafficking
so bizarre well now it gets even weirder
so another Mutual of mine sent me
this um she saw our
segment and
this girl I don't remember she was used
to wear Teddy fresh and she would wear
Teddy fresh a all the time so I followed
her like oh years ago Lil Mochi remember
her yep I know her so she's doing only
fans now okay and so I don't know who
this guy Z Wilson
is but this motherfucker's out here
messaging people oh my God the same
thing here he mess her you
should link with the agent I work with
here La he does a lot to help me help
make me money through brand deals
Partnerships management let me know if
you're interested I'll plug you that's
not that's weird but now she's like look
at all these messages I'm getting from
people the same
hey love do you have a team hi kind
of random but you pop Hi how are you it
would be nice like they're all trying to
hey U might be ridiculous question but
hi this is so out of the
blue you should link with the agent I
work with wait what yo what's up I work
with building and hey hope this isn't
too random but so it's women and men oh
my
God isn't that creepy and they all have
the same kind of like yep hey my bad
approach casual approach the these are
famous these are like real people with
like real follow I mean Austin McBroom
is doing
this
huh can we look up some like here this
guy is the biggest one here Mark Thomas
and it's specifically only fan girls yes
H I think what are they trying to do uh
if I had a guess I mean the adult film
industry you know is so predatory and
like misogynistic and now uh that women
finally have a platform where they don't
need to be managed by people and don't
get taken advantage of like only fans
now these guys are stepping in and they
offer services I I've heard something
like this similar a few years ago about
a big Creator doing this where like
they'll offer like to promote them and
then they'll have people that will send
out messages for them on their behalf to
like handle a higher literally what
Andrew Tate did yeah pretty much
literally I mean they'll they'll sign
people up the same way they used to do
it on YouTube just lying like small
channels to be like we get higher rates
that's a straight up lie we have a
marketing team we have an ad team we'll
promote you it's like okay I don't know
anything and then they just lock you
into a horrific
contract um a big lie
so who is this guy Mark Thomas like is
anyone I just sent you his Instagram
page and then this guy also Z Wilson
like who are these people Z Wilson's a
reality TV star yeah I see he's got like
an IMDb profile this isn't this this
child is not sending no that's not no it
just keeps WR all right so this guy yeah
yeah look at his description in his bio
professional eimp Oh e okay well at
least he's up front and if you go to the
what the hell co-owner it's a
gym he owns a gym and a pimping
service this dude this is the dude
that's going to protect
you wow this guy this dude's gonna get
your
money
nah Austin on the other hand now that
dude is someone I would want to pimp
me um I feel like these people need to
be I don't know these people need to get
called out a little bit like this is a
huge exposed look at these freaks all of
them yeah super weird so Z Wilson is a
reality guy and then what's with the
women doing this like damn yeah these
are obviously not girls
girls who's Katy
lordal let's see here's her Instagram
she's got a million followers as I said
every Epstein needs a gelle her link is
to a modeling
service it looks like
did you s oh you sent it or no no but I
could send
it like there's a lot of lays in here so
my my guess is that for them to be
debasing themselves it must be really
lucrative for them this girl has decent
engagement I mean 300,000
likes they're it's not even them I'm
sure they just they the agency's like
I'm seeing that first guy people are
saying he was on musically back in the
day oh God perfect I see the perfect
line from that to
epimp that was the thing that like
turned into Tik Tok right yeah
musically gotcha I I think actually this
is probably what's happening the agency
pays them to just be able to log in and
DM people all day yeah yeah so that they
say I'll pay you they're just recruiting
I'll pay you they'll this is what they
do probably I'll pay you flat rate and
then anyone else that we get to sign up
then you get a lifetime commission
that's crazy big difference is how you
pay it
back right always think about that he's
so right so all these people should be
ashamed they should all be shouted out
like you so that's why they're all the
same because it's the same people doing
it
yep people are saying that Jan sha Jen
Shaw from Salt Lake used to do this too
I'm actually I'm looking into that right
now she's less surprising than these
people I mean she's in prison for fraud
so she pled guilty one charge of
conspiracy to commit wire fraud and
connection with
telemarketing no I yeah I know that but
is that Rel I don't know what they mean
no that was for she was scamming old
people yeah that was what she was
doing uh here's another one Nia I've had
like top creators DM me these and they
will you into replying and then they'll
give you someone's number I have
multiple dude this they're taking these
people's legitimacy to uh to get in the
door with people and then they pass them
off the actual pimps whatever I have not
heard anybody talk about this but this
is really gross this is really
gross man these people are all such
scumbags Jesus
Christ well thank you to little Mochi
doll for sending this this is actually
awesome she said I know this week you
made a podcast about manager scams and I
know you always bring light to it so I
thought maybe you would want a few more
screenshots of kind of famous people
doing the same oh she says people from
love Island well I don't I don't expect
great things from them to be
fair but well they probably just see it
as a quick pay and they don't look much
into it just kind of crazy I don't think
they care I don't think they care you
know what I mean yeah they they're in
their they could look at the DMS you
know I mean it's in their inbox
yeah oh man we don't care we sure
don't so I don't know what do we do
about
it I guess I just got to know you just
point it out I hope that don't fall for
this is being approached by messages
like that is not taking
debate I think it can't be
I feel like it can't be that effective
but surely it's working on some
people especially this
massive uh they have this massive
affiliate program going
on so that's what's Austin's been up to
yeah congratulations they're in their
sorry
um he's on a great trajectory oh Al
Alexis says I'm top 10% o I haven't
uploaded in a year and I get these
messages all the
time let's run up Dink D prices y'all oh
hey
gabey happy New Year happy year G First
Call of the New Year my friend yeah baby
yeah 2024 baby oh my
God how's your year
been oh it's getting there it's getting
in like a l
it's getting there like it's get when
you say getting there like to 2025 is
that what you mean or something
else like good it's the start of it I
say it's the start of it something good
okay okay okay something good nice shirt
thanks Gabe are you signed to an
agency this might sound random
but I'm finding one I got you I know a
guy what are you eating there that looks
good yeah I'm having Taco
Bell hell yeah brother my they always
come back around
always my we might need to do
the first Taco Bell of the
Year dude Taco Bell actually hold
on so let me say this without saying it
I always say Taco Bell needs to pay me
mute the mics mute the mic oh oh
no don't say it don't say it maybe
they'll come back don't say it why don't
say it
but maybe saying it we'll bring it back
that's what I mean you got to keep the
pressure on that's what I thought but I
don't know I how many chalupas have got
my ass only brands at Taco Bell
strategic here
Ethan my whole brand is Taco Bell you
have to think about this carefully Gabe
I love
you I love you so I was gonna say I keep
saying Taco Bell me to pay me they
emailed
us and they had a pretty fat nice deal
lined up for some social posts and it
was just insta stories and stuff like
that wow cuz at first they're like I
they're like I we need some social posts
and I says I don't do I don't even post
the social media anymore all I do is
insta stories but they just asked for
reals stories and Tik Tok is that can do
that M um and Lena just informed me that
they said they gave it to somebody
else yes
did we email them back like when I said
I passed because initially I
passed maybe that's why but and then I
was like and then I read it again so
Ethan told me about it and he was like I
just passed on it and I was like why
what because I didn't want to I didn't
want to post I didn't want to do like a
main post to Instagram when I don't post
anything there it would be so hacky M
don't you think it's still Taco Bell
though we should have done it on the
podcast stuff you should just do it for
free I do do it for free yeah just give
it to them give them what they want
anyway Taco Bell you guys please hook me
up this is ridiculous what Gabe how
about some free Taco Bell we can start
there let's start there at least they
sent us gift cards in the past yeah once
yeah $10 gift cards you can't this day
and age how much a taco
cost five bucks yeah dude I spent like
70 bucks on Taco Ball the other day 70
yeah how much is our order for the whole
crew though I just like I just put all
the stuff I want to try how much I could
spend and what did you didn't eat it all
right well I tried it oh so you you
tried everything it's a tasting menu
were you by yourself or you with
somebody yeah just aone my God
bro and you weren't masturbating were
you cuz I I was thinking about the guy
in the Taco Bell masturbating for no
hours yeah get I no no it was Burger
King it was Burger it was Burger King MC
McDonald my my nobody would do that in
big difference my
bad my bad yeah let's order a Taco Bell
what should we what also did you suggest
a minute ago that a taco would be
$5 how out of touch are you who seal
Booth I know it's like three bucks I was
rounding drama yeah but like chalupa
Supremes are like six bucks taco supreme
I mean that's like 350 isn't it a
Chalupa Supreme is 459 here's the issue
a well that's a
you got to you got to go get it through
the drivethru there because if you order
here it's always cold it's
always late you know yeah yeah it ruins
the experience you need to get it fresh
it's true when I whenever we order the
Shell by the time it gets here like
sticks to the paper yeah yeah it's not
still tastes good though I like
it fresh tacos right about that I get
mine fresh every time we go through the
drive-thru yeah baby what did you
order I ordered the the 12 pack the half
the hard shell and half with the soft
shell 12 the 12 just for you
tacos was 12 just for you
Gabe no for me is whoever wants it oh
you're good
man you're a good man drive him over
let's see I guess it's not that much I
mean you get a double stack Taco for two
bucks spicy potato tacos $1 that makes
no sense I think Theiss SAS are a bit
too much they're like seven bucks
probably because they have tocks they
have to use like real
ingredients I think it's like six or
seven weekend midnight snack everybody
Taco Bell at midnight
true uh nacho cheese Dorito Los Tacos
Loco
Supreme is
340 340 after tax stand what's that put
you at almost four bucks yeah okay all
all right fair enough the basic ass Taco
is still like a buck right two basic ass
Taco crunchy taco is $1.79 there you
go that's cheap God Bless America dude
so we all ordering right yes okay oh we
are yeah okay well Zach I mean Zach is
Zach's Zach's suggestion is nothing
that's
unacceptable like soggy t is better than
no Taco Bell yeah no
that's no dispute there all right so um
okay Gabe you've inspired us today thank
you
yeah guys are the best love you Budd
look all these there's so many people in
chat damn I need to get Taco Bell now
pay us that's every time pay us every
single goddamn time hey up Gabe uh do
you have any New Year's resolutions
continue what I'm doing losing some
weight and going to new fashion rebuild
myself that's my New Year resolution
bigger better faster
stronger oh yeah I have no doubt that
you'll achieve all your dreams this year
Gabe thank
you give it up give it up for
Gabe
yeah um
oh I have more is this more related
messages AB this was just another fan
just sent me this um from Little
pump wait what little pump is doing this
I mean no surprise he's fell off so hard
wait what the so so who once just a
fan sent this in uh yeah so Lil pump
goes yo and then they says hi low pump
what up where are you from Greece oh
that's fire
so I work with a really good of
management and I think we can get
something going so hit me back if you're
interested get what going the girls
already have something
going you know what I mean absolutely no
it's just a bunch of there's no
there's leeches Yeah Lil pump is that
the dude that collabed with um Kanye
yeah I I remember you saying you liked
him I what happened to Lil
pump now what
this is uh her name is Reb RB wait hold
on this guy's
still three weeks ago 500,000 likes
that's actually more than I thought
200,000 I mean it's with the President
congratulations 200,000 this one with
Nana got 230 he's still hanging in there
kind
of bro you got to stop oh he's with Theo
Von looks like somebody's backstage at
the oh it's a UFC thing I see
um dude what are you doing man
embarrassing godd
damn
call them out guys everyone at home
who's get getting these let's call them
out send them in we're going to name and
shame them all if you did this you
thought this was secret in the
background no more we are
coming for you and we are coming in
waves and we are going to say your name
and we're going to show your picture we
are coming send to me if you
want um all right uh Gabe it's been a
joy to to see you and to hear from you
love seeing you at the live show it's
great seeing you and Nick Nick there you
guys are the best you guys are
nice got to inspire some more that's
what I'm thinking all right well we're
here we're here whatever you got going
on we're here for
[Applause]
it
[Music]
all right Gabe nice to see you all
right
bye speaking of Kanye um we there's
actually a really nice Kanye update
Kanye has apologized
to I didn't know that if the day would
happen or what I've seen a lot of people
saying um he was just a couple years
late yeah if Kanye was doing his shtick
today I think he would be voted
president he would have become president
yeah so true early you mean say what you
said late you he was early it was ahead
of his time two years early
yes um what happened to Lil pump is he
good still
Ian wait what sorry Lil pump I remember
you saying you like Lil pump what when
did I say that there what well Kanye and
Lil pump did this collab where they were
in like the bottle or some sh and I
remember you say I don't know I haven't
heard from him in a while he's been kind
of
gone I'm going to go to the bathroom
well models are hearing from him he was
performing at like uh Trump's uh rally
and stuff oh God we just saw on
Instagram now that's falling
off yeah so uh con
West he's come around he's apologized to
the Jewish community in Hebrew now taken
down wait why do you erase
it why'd he erase it he's out again he
pulled he's out on the Jews what's her
name the apologize and remove the
apology you know what I thought too
about Kanye cuz he's he's like a cont
Aran he does stuff to go against the
grain and to get attention maybe now
hating Jews has become way too
mainstream and loving Jews is now right
the awesome Counter Culture yeah loving
Jews is counterculture as right
now so wait where's the translation Z
got erase uh our native speaker just
walked away so there was two images in
his post it was the Hebrew and then the
Engish
English let me see why do you oh I have
the translation here why did he um why
did he erase it man should have left it
up for the people he says I sincerely
apologize to the Jewish Community for
any unintended Outburst caused by my
words or actions it was not my
atttention or hurt or disrespect and I
deeply regret any pain I may have
caused I am committed what are you
talking about to starting with myself
and learning from this experience to
ensure greater sensitivity understanding
the future your forgiveness is important
to me and I am committed to making
amends and pro promoting
Unity erase and he erased that what he's
so
nuts what the my question
is this um is Kanye back on the playlist
I like
Hitler wait I'm getting more is this
another new one this is from uh novu
who's a big streamer and fan of the
show is she a o yes okay
I believe so actually I mean it it adds
up yeah so Lil pump says yo yo where you
from same same exact line I live in
Austin you okay no he didn't say that
fire he said okay that's what's up I'm
in Miami oh that's not fire I see you do
o Austin isn't fire like Greece no fire
I see you do o do you have a team I was
going to see if you wanted to work
interested in being a part of pump's
Playhouse e oh no
nobody should be a part of pump's
Playhouse vomit puke in my
mouth you want to be a part of pump's
Playhouse holy that is vile that I
mean this is incredible we're just
they're coming in now the
messages um what do I want from Taco
Bell I want a taco
supreme I want
a taco Supreme's hard to beat you know
it's just mhm it's good
I've I've been going hard on the hard
tackles lately but I got three three
soft ones because the it don't it don't
arrive hard that's actually a good
strategy personally I just don't like
the softs I mean me neither but I'm just
so done with a soggy tackle yeah I feel
that yeah I for sure feel that you know
what you guys are going to freak out cuz
this order is objectively insane
but this is how I like my burrito from
there
okay bean and cheese with extra
onions and extra hot
sauce and that's it that's the end of
the list oh that's not crazy I mean it's
not that the extra onions things I feel
like T so many yeah cuz the thing is so
usually they put a few in and because
it's so gooey I find the texture is
really nice so when there's more onions
it's just like it's not just a bunch of
Goo it's a nice mixture of textures okay
the burrito doesn't seem not that crazy
not that crazy no I put on on my tackles
cuz it's free you got that lener do I
need to write it no I got it okay and
then
um two is probably enough for me
anything more than that is pushing in I
feel like two tacos I got a taco and a
burrito oh yeah that's yeah but they're
the burrito is like a tiny little thing
yeah part of me want the third
one
you know resist what did you get a taco
and a burrito okay that's fire what taco
and burrito you get Supreme oh see the
Supreme is a lot more food than mine oh
okay you know just hit three and eat two
and then you see what
happens yeah so get me another taco
supreme okay two Taco Supremes one onion
burrito and you want the hard shell
right for yes please okay thank you
oh my computer's
Frozen completely Frozen yeah yeah the
heck should I restart it I guess yeah
all right I'm going to restart it come
on
[Music]
Dale I'm holding the power button
and there's just a pile of shredded
paper where ducky was wait the power
isn't working either that's not do
uh-uh holy I'm getting so many
messages about little
pump I was just on Twitter now I'm on
Instagram yeah wow this is a fertile
topic for a video essay as or whoever
does that yeah I don't have the
time for that anymore but it is a
really good topic for brand drama dude
22 are you watching
uh I a great
Z 22 social media boys so cute a they
have little babies so cute wait where is
that I want to do that it's one of those
like uh Japanese grocery stores you know
where they have like a bunch of cute
stuff
oh the boys went to one of those cute
stores and they have little tiny stroll
art for them that's awesome he's super
cute yeah where's ducky he was right
under Hill yeah so what's up with the
laptop we're trying to fix it okay it's
restarting you want to read some of the
messages you're getting AB uh yeah I was
just trying to save them all but
um let's see well
this I'm I want to go through and
actually ask everyone if it's okay if I
share their name but in terms of
messages this one Creator sent me a
bunch of different ladies that reached
out to her um hey hope this isn't too
random but I ended up on your page and I
just had the feeling you'd rock it with
the same agent I'm with seriously he
does everything for me let me know if
you're down I can connect
you same message yeah another
one hey babe I might be able to point
you in the right direction of someone
who can help you generate more revenue
from chatting have you ever used a 247
trained chatting team who can maximize
your earnings uh would you be in a
position to handle chatting to a larger
fan base by yourself yeah so this is
what I was talking about the thing that
cracks me up about this is they're
trying to get a percentage from this
person for doing
like a BAS basic job that anyone
in her life could do for her for her and
then you could pay that someone in your
life a really good salary and not pay
some scumbag Andrew Tate wannabe a
percentage of your it's like no if you
want to if you want to take that route
which I guess I understand it it's like
un only fans the girls don't actually
chat with people they just they have
other people chatting with them not
always and I I feel like that's the uh
that's the tricky part in like talking
about this because and then it screws
over only fans models who are legit
talking to their audience because now
their potential revenue is going to be
messed with because people are afraid
that it's dudes responding to them or
whoever anything anyone else I'm pretty
sure I don't know someone told us that
recently that it's basically all well if
you're a Top
Model there's way too much for one
person to answer I'm sure definitely
yeah but that's kind of wild that people
think they're talking to the
models although if you're paying
hundreds of dollars I guess m it's fair
to assume that
eh all right we are
restarting restarting um while we wait
here's another one from Little pump uh
it says what up look I'm sure you get
mad people hitting you up about of
management would you be open to at least
talk we got a real good team and we
would love to hop on a call with you and
at least get the chance to explain and
show you
everything that
one's a little more transparent oh
that's a little pump though when you put
it in context
yeah and then someone this one's from
Bill
Clinton the
hell kidding
jokes by the way Clint go ahead ab and
then I'll I'll move on to something else
I know that was it just another creator
said that uh ultimately they just have
an assistant call you and ask you
questions yeah God damn it still trying
to calibrate here Discord is not opening
now but hopefully it resolves on its own
you just close it reopen it fix itself
speaking of Bill
Clinton that the Epstein stuff came out
yeah and Billy boy's all over it and um
did we watch the clip of him somebody
asked him about it oh and his answer was
so bad I was like this did
everything that they say he did I
haven't seen that it's really short but
you're like oh my God this guy's that he
did that can you find that yeah I'm
looking for right now you'd think that
that's the one question he's prepared
for right bizar right wful demon gifted
50 thank you so much that's nice think
is this one that you're talking about
does this look correct uh my Discord
doesn't work I Tred close here I'll just
uh pull it
over this one yes that's
it any comments on the allegation of
your connection with
[Music]
Jeffrey he says I think the evidence
speaks that's his response any comments
on allegation of your connection with
Jeffrey
[Music]
I hear evidence is in yeah the evidence
is in which is like are you admitting
that you did do that he's like yeah what
evidence is he talking about the stuff
that just got unsealed I guess he's
saying that uh even though he was one of
the names in the documents but he wasn't
uh exp uh explicitly detailed as someone
that did something uh
there was I remember in a dep position
also that that clip of Clinton was from
2022 oh was recent but I mean he's been
known a known associate for years so
um was it Bill Clinton some Gardener
test testified that he saw Billy
boy out at the um the island with with
Jeff that's crazy I that dude the only
reason that Epstein would be so brazen
and so open and Shameless is if he was
like got the president with the
president the like the president
is kids with him also I feel
like that question made him giddy like
he he did not stop smiling dude he's
reminiscing
that days yeah yeah I often think about
the island on
days um Discord will not
open why why why why why why why why why
why why
Dan is on his way over it is not put
your clothes on I ain't ready
for that I'm on a
Discord yeah but there's all kind MJ was
in the unsealed Epstein do that one's
kind of surprised people
yes a previous Israeli Prime Minister
bar oh but and I should say like being
on this list does not
mean that you
partook but it is does mean something it
is does mean something you know it's
suspicious yeah it's not a list you want
to be on no Trump was all over it we
know
that it's like Santa's naughty list you
don't want to be on
it okay thank you Dan so here's the
Epstein list revealed after being
unsealed defamation lawsuit
uh filed by Virginia Roberts Guffy
against Maxwell Guffy accused Epstein
and Maxwell of abuse case was settled in
2017 and Maxwell was later sentenced to
20 years in prison free my
girl nah free G Lane
man we Canna leave her in
there uh so here's notable names that
were
unsealed I guess people were really
working hard to keep this list sealed M
okay so prince Andrew we know that that
dude did that absolutely he did
that and a des an ad
deposition sober claimed that prince
Andrew put his hand on my breast in 2022
the Royal settled a suit claiming sexual
abuse that was followed by another
person Virginia Guffy and of course
there's that infamous picture of him
with that
girl uh with like a really young girl or
not she's like teenager I mean a child
for sure oh yeah that's not yeah he did
that
man here it is
yeah oh God I haven't seen these ones I
haven't se wait what the I haven't
seen these
ones who is this person do we know who
this person
is I have not seen this I thought that
was the picture you no this is good I'm
just shocked by it I thought I was
thinking never seen this this is the one
I was thinking of and this girl accused
him that's that's Virginia Guffy okay
yeah and it's like dude you're
ain't no goddamn way yeah with Maxwell
just beaming in the
background
creeps why are you hanging out with her
how old was she at time like just answer
that why is there like a 16-year-old
girl why is your hand over her that
ain't no hover hand like that's this
picture alone is already
inappropriate he should abdicate was he
stripped of Royal
duties uh yeah yeah he got he got
in some titles taken away or something I
mean who cares right like he
still he still lives in a castle Yeah he
stripped of his military affiliations
and Royal Patron they really they really
they really showed him so did he does he
not have a title anymore does he still
Prince he's still Prince
see I feel like now that lizz's in a box
this type of got to end the Royal
the king is his brother the king is his
brother yeah so that's probably not
happening old sausage finger old sausage
fingers yeah he's like
scar uh yes he's like
scar all right Charles is Noosa give me
a break what what's the story with this
one this one's super creepy it's that
one's been around for for years too none
of this is uh the Bill Clinton stuff is
really new I just it's new to me so I'm
curious is this girl an accuser or
something or she's a victim it says in
this Daily Mail article so here she is
with Epstein and then here she is giving
Clinton a back massage and then here
they are on another separate occasion
together dude what the why are you
letting a a like she's underage there
huh I'm not sure if she's underage right
there I don't know yet wow I I think
that's that M
right like dude not
always not always yeah I mean they had
girls of various ages but the Virginia
Guffy one she was
underage what a creepy what is
wrong how is this real like how is this
actually
real such a disturbing says in the
article she's operation oh she was 22 at
the time
yeah oh my God
this dude was a sick dude yeah
Bill Clinton you're caught
slick
Willie so that's obvious uh Joanna
testified Jeffrey told her Clinton likes
them young referring to girls yeah
that's
gross well when he had the affair with
Monica Lewinsky I think she was like 19
or something she was such a she was a
victim
of and her life was absolutely destroyed
dude her story and I remember I was a
kid when all this was happening and I
remember everybody hated her
right they thought she was a and
she was like just a nasty little she
just wanted clout oh she was 22 and like
uh the more you learn about it yeah her
Amazon doc was really really really good
yeah I watched that yeah we watched that
y wow Bill
Clinton the second batch of documents
2011 email from Miss Guffy to journalist
Sharon churcher including an accusation
that Bill Clinton had threatened Vanity
Fair reporters about
stories writing stories on Epstein yeah
I believe
that Bill Clinton walked into vny fair
and threatened them not to write sex
trafficking articles about his good
friend
Jeffrey wow I'd like would Vanity Fair
be able to confirm that I mean love to
know if that's true yeah somebody should
follow up on that love to know CU that
that is a Smoking Gun right there if
vand Fair confirms that Clinton has
mentioned 70 three times wow brother
that's a lot they were like best friends
that's a lot what is this one AB this is
by far the worst one oh that's your mom
isn't it that is my mom oh
no oh no oh no your poor
mom yeah stay away from from my mom this
picture is inappropriate stay away from
her that was years ago at get J stay
away from
her Robert F Kennedy Jr everybody's
favorite
antivaccine brain uh the brain membrane
brain blood barrier
guy my my favorite he harps on about
that a lot yeah he's a he's crazy psycho
uh really a weird dangerous dude wish
cam was here got the best RFK impression
yeah he's the guy who's like you know B
if you look see I haven't heard his
voice in a long time if you think M I
got to hear it hold on let me hear his
voice I could pull up a video yeah but
you know it is it is an unfortunate
condition that he has that makes him
speak like that maybe we shouldn't yeah
of course I thought he was doing it on
purpose for clout he's doing it for
clout and donations he's doing it for
donations let's see Robert Kennedy Jr
was one of his celebrity guests sex
offender former house manager claimed in
newly unsealed documents the ex-employee
Juan alesi listed Kennedy as one of
numerous high-profile visitors to his
Mansion Kennedy acknowledged television
interview that he did fly on Epstein's
jet twice this actually happened and I
remember watching this and I was like
wait hold on they really skimmed over
that but this article doesn't have the
video what is this
article
uh here I got
it I think it was on like Fox News or
something yeah and he just casually
mentioned that he flew on his airplane
twice cam sent a voice note oh no cam
had a voice note oh God who is this who
is this Poor
Boy the whole family AB no that looks
underage the whole family I think I was
underage oh that's just
inappropriate the a or yeah the a odds
are really oh my God look at the one
person behind the one eye one eye that's
an Illuminati thing clearly a
setup here let me play this voice note
hello to everyone watching the H3
podcast
right now it's me Robert F Kennedy
Jr wow how'd you get a hold of him so
fast Pam that was that was
impressive I want to say I really want
to say that that's good I was only on EP
Highland
twice he was a good man I don't believe
the
charges please protect your brain bar
barer your brain blood barrier the the
5G is breaking our blood
barrier we got that clip I'm I'm
drowning over I'm looking for it yeah I
have so many articles about him saying
it on another Channel they'll proba some
EP being made public about to be made
public back in November you told
Newsweek you'd been on Epstein's plane
once in the early '90s you told Fox News
in December you're on his plane twice is
there any he's refering
he's referring back to the December
interview which is the one that I that I
want this is after he admit
it okay well then I'll keep looking he
said it was in
December he says that in that video the
transcript
says I just want the video I'm looking
for the video Yeah I want the video I'll
give it to you but in the meantime well
how do you link a look at this old ass
article not a video in it give me a
break okay we'll wait for that so shout
out to RFK
JR this one's weird David
Copperfield
Yeah and I'll make the charges
disappear I always had a feeling that
magicians are weird people I think this
is it that might be a hot take and this
is why it's especially this is
especially interesting cuz he's on Fox
News talking to this
who is on the bullhorn screaming about
Epstein all the time so check this out
fire the FBI
director well I would certainly question
about these issues I think you were
right to point out um the the uh the dis
the a different application of
ofs here
on also I think
he doesn't get
L with my wife on Jeffrey B's jet were
you
back director because this guy is
politicized the be Jesus out of the
bureau you weren't ever on Jeffrey
Epstein's jet were
you I was on Jeffrey hen's jet two times
I was on it in
1993 and I was on it in and I went to
Florida
with my wife and uh two children to
visit my mom over Easter um my my wife
had some kind of relationship with Glen
Maxwell and they offered us a ride to
Palm Beach so I went then and on another
occasion I flew again with my family
with I think four of my children and um
and uh and marry my wife to rap City
South
Dakota to go fossil hunting for a
weekend really this
been very open about this
from the beginning this was in
93 30 years ago it was before
anybody knew about Jeffrey ebstein's uh
you know his nefarious issues and I
agree with you that these all of this
information should RFK Jun I was On's
plane twice and we we should get real
answers on What happened to Jeffrey
abstein and any of the highlevel
political people that he was
involved you are one of those people
absolutely Trans on his your your wife
was friends with G Lane that's weird
would have any
reactions hiding that is you might not
even get a chance to do that because
Mark Elias the Hot Shot Democrat
election attorney is trying to basically
kick you off ballots yep no
interest no interest in all a sudden
they don't care all of a sudden this guy
doesn't care about the EP right on by
that so let's see
Copperfield and I this might be
inappropriate but I'll say it and we'll
make ah it feels bad saying it but I'll
say it no and David Copperfield imion he
goes and I make her in
disappeared
bad not funny it's not something to joke
about no yeah certainly not nothing to
do magic tricks about you know what's
crazy when when I was a kid I went to a
copper field show once and at the very
end his last trick was making someone
disappear to an island oh yeah I
swear to God oh no it was like a someone
supposedly from the audience he puts him
in like this thing and then he goes like
that and there's like a live feed of
like some Island that he's on
oh something tells me that that's an
illusion yeah I'd like to offer a quote
from my good friend Jimmy Lee bring him
young bring them in stilettos But be
sure to bring him
Jeffrey wow that's so good that is
really good it got better over the phone
cam says that one great and Alex Jones
those are his what is yeah so that's
David Copperfield we met him actually
when we went to Vegas that a long time
ago with with uh host Malone yeah and we
met him
backstage that's interesting last time
you met Chris Angel yeah they're just
there dime a dozen in Vegas all these
magicians
um AB cuz you asked people are saying
it's not Cheryl I don't know who is
Cheryl yeah was I think X I think
Cheryl's newer okay do we like Cheryl do
you know that when David Copperfield was
in town he gives Jeffrey Epstein tickets
and Jeffrey gives him some young women
to attend those shows the lawyer asked
and how do you know that those girls are
invited backstage after the show Alan
dtz that's not a that this is not a
surprise I mean I didn't to read this
part that guy did it Michael
Jackson not a surprise the fame
well I didn't think here here's my thing
with Michael and this is why he's
innocent ab and I'm with you the PE the
the girls on the island not his
type well I figured he had his own
distribution system you think yeah but I
guess it makes sense well let's see did
you ever meet anybody famous when you
were with Jeffrey I met Michael Jackson
oh really and where was that at his
house in Palm Beach at jeffy's house in
Palm Beach did you give him massage I
did not she said because of course why
would she I think Michael had his own
Supply thoughts on that
AB you know I was debating uh bringing
this up and I think it might clarify
some stuff to people because we always
bring MJ thing I didn't want to but I
brought you something from Michigan and
might explain some stuff okay AB bring
the documents to the uh AB got
[Applause]
receipts wel okay
so wait hold the phone bro you
save yo 2004 how old were you 2004 I was
uh I was about 10 holy you
almost that was it was one time
and here did you go did you go yeah I
went you
did I did wait you never told us you
went to Wonderland never
Neverland kidding me went to Neverland
wait let me read this what wait my I'm
flabbergasted hold on this is even
bigger than finding out that Lena was a
beauty queen which we already knew but
you guys just like keep dropping this
here's the official invitation when he
was 10 years old Neverland Ranch welcome
to oh this is the itinerary
yeah so they gave you an itinerary so
how did you get invited to Neverland
Ranch so my dad is really close with uh
someone who is part of mtown basically
he's the nephew of Barry Gordy and uh
yeah okay so through them and their
family I went with them as family
friends basically did you meet Michael I
did you never told us that did you spend
time with him at all yeah I mean that
day how many kids were or how many
people were with you guys there was like
uh
I think there was two other families and
there was about probably about like 20
people in total was he interested in you
no I don't mean that but was he talking
to you like did he give you attention
like yeah he was nice he introduced all
of us I mean he introduced himself to
all of us when we first got there here's
the itinerary welcome tell us everything
about that day let me read this cuz this
is going to be good Neverland Valley
Ranch welcome to December 17 2004 10:00
a.m. to 400 p.m. 10 a. to 3 p.m. the
arcade room will be open did you go to
the arcade room yeah what' you guys do
in there uh they had I don't remember a
lot they had a really cool like Star
Wars like like a X-Wing game that's all
I really
remember um 10 11:00 a.m. to 3 p p.m.
the zoo will be open did you go to the
zoo uh we did well we walked by the zoo
there's like a train that takes you
through it all sort of like a a driveby
thing and Michael was with you all day
um pretty much you were with your
parents you said no I was with the other
family
okay so there were adults present yeah
the whole time
mhm was Michael by
himself or did he have a little kid next
to
him I mean there was a bunch of us there
does he have an Entourage of
children cuz it makes they makes it
sound like that when I read about it a
Peter Piper type situation where he's
just being Trail it makes it sound like
that well from what I understood from
watching the documentaries and listening
to victims it seems like his thing was
that he would get into almost like Co a
relationship with one boy yeah at a time
and it was like they were dating
yeah um lunch will be served at 11:30
p.m. Park closed during lunch what was
for lunch do you
remember
um
I'm sorry I'm just with you guys
I I had to get you back for I was
with me I had I'm sorry I'm
sorry I I I here the whole
timear I'm like you guys with me
too much about this I had to get you
back I'm sorry wow I was confused ready
you know I was thinking like this thing
is a mint pention like you must have
taken
crazy this is not how we start 2024 wow
he play that hell a straight he had me
starting to believe but I was yeah wait
where did you get this from the whole
image and stuff so like uh there was
like this MJ like fan thing collector's
edition thing at a flea market and it
has like little like pullout things like
the replicas of like invitations to
Neverland and a bunch of other things
and I was like I wonder if I could cuz I
know it's inevitably going to come up
and it's funny it was before this Stein
thing I was like I wonder if I could
have this and I could convince them that
I went to
Neverland well that would explain why
you riding for him so hard it all made
sense like all the other kids do like M
Clen and all these people you
know that was such a betrayal right now
I'm sorry I feel guilty ly to El I
didn't feel guilty ly to you Ethan but
no you shouldn't you shouldn't you
shouldn't I was asking too many
questions though I was going to ask you
to shake your hand wow you spent the
whole day with him that's
crazy God I wish that was true that
would been this was like wow that's
that's a good one though I enjoyed it
thank you thank you I enjoyed believing
that while I did believe
it oh man
damn I guess but here you have a
normally you're so skeptical of EV like
everything Ethan like well because it
made sense I was like this mother it all
just kind of clicked together yeah yeah
that's I mean good job maybe also yeah
you like added cuz he's not easy to get
one over on the photos the map too
people were talking about it where'd you
get the map it's the same thing if you
see the back you see where it's torn on
the back it says replica so I had to rip
it
off it's yeah this is what we had you
keep that this map is pretty interesting
mhm ballet Welcome Center Neverland
Gates electric train station Lake
Neverland Neverland Gardens bro this guy
did that there's 49 locations on
this game room main residence main train
station pool TP Village Flamingo Island
train station dining area games and
prizes Nature Preserve Nestle Lounge
wait he's got a sponsorship
Nesley people just as disappointed in
the chat everybody wanted it to be true
yeah you got
yeah on show he had bears tigers
orangutans giraffes
elephants wow AB the the the mtown
records connection was very clever I
pulled it out of my assz I I I
didn't it was like a loose idea I had a
while ago and then when I was in
Michigan I I totally forgot that I had
those so I brought him with me just in
case cuz I was like it's going to come
up but I didn't have time to think of a
story
but that was good man thank you thank
you I wish it was true thank you yeah I
was you know this was going to become a
4-Hour more podcast just talking about
this I had so many questions my jaw was
literally on the
floor but what do you think about him
being in Epstein's uh notebook does that
surprise you or
no
uh I mean yeah I was surprised by a lot
of the names on there I was surprised by
MJ I didn't expect it well as you uh
just read um you know they asked if the
victim had had any inappropriate
interaction with him and they said no
yeah was a girl mhm uh right true true
you ever seen a little girl at Neverland
Ranch there may have been I I don't know
there there to I'm kidding I'm kidding
there was a fan of the show um of the
podcast who reached out to me years ago
and sent me pictures of her at Neverland
with uh with Michael I'm kidding of
course there was little girls there
although I'd like to know the percentage
I'd like to know the per capita yeah I
don't know cuz I'm telling you that was
8020 split easy I was curious what
happened with the place and apparently I
just found a article that's the title is
billionaire pal of Bill Clinton bought
the estate for 22 million Bill Clinton
wait no no no hold on billionaire
pal friend of Bill Clinton I so I
remember they were trying to sell it and
nobody wanted it it started at like 200
million or something and it was on sale
for so long nobody wanted it to
deal with that it sold for 20
million that's crazy that's like a 90%
markdown damn it's
crazy I mean you're kind of inheriting a
bunch of like of a
mess par on there and stuff yeah yeah
it's like Ferris wheels and you got
to get rid of how much that cost that
stuff is all still there you think
honestly I have no idea it is it seems
like it from this article somebody got
got to get rid of it and would you
really get rid of it they're upkeeping
it too wait they're upkeeping it yeah
from these pictures it looks part of
what the article is saying specifically
the person that finally bought it like
restored it okay well that makes sense
then yeah they must be one of these
crazy MJ
fans I told you guys a story about when
we were shopping for we were looking at
homes yeah and we went into this one
house that had like a MJ Shrine yeah you
did tell us about so weird it gave such
weird Vibes I wanted to get out of that
house
yeah um
Stephen Hawking that one blew everybody
away 2015 Mrs Guffy Cil claim in the US
an email from Epstein to Maxwell surface
revealing Epstein's request for Maxwell
to issue a reward to counter guffy's
claim involving Professor Steven Hawking
in an alleged underage
orgy yep is this when he's in the wheel
in the chair oh yeah he was in the from
like 17 years old yes right there what
wait so
he articulated that that's exactly what
he wanted meaning well we don't
know he if that's the case he I right he
but he would have had to like think
about it it and then it would have had
to say
it uh I guess so yeah hypothetically yes
we could have stopped all right uh you
can issue a reward to any of Virginia's
friends or family that come forward and
help prove her allegations are false the
strongest is the Clinton dinner and the
new version in the Virgin Virgin Islands
that Stephen Hawking participated in
underage orgy so that that's what Mrs
Guffy said yeah and then this email was
pertain this was Epstein emailing
jislain saying we need to quash this the
strongest and the he's pointing out that
the strongest accusations that she has
is the Clinton dinner and the stepen
Hawkings or that's seems to imply that
there is something behind it if worried
Ste Hawkings orgy yikes so was he my
God I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that I'm gonna he'll be like hey uh
Stephen I'm going to need you to stop
associating with Epstein that guy's
trouble I'm afraid I can't do that
all right you listen here uh Stephen
it's not a good look okay you're making
lots of progress in the world of astrop
physic physics and you got to get your
together man I'm
sorry did you have an orgy with underage
girls yes or no I'm afraid I can't do
that that might be true I mean he is a
paraplegic or is he a
paraplegic I think that would be the
term for it I'm not sure I'm afraid how
be def he lost the the movement from
what was the the thing he
had stepen
[Music]
Hawkings let's see uh amot Tropic
lateral ALS ALS that's much easier to
say than what I was attempting to make
my way through man yes
ALS so everybody always wondered like it
was like a miracle that he lived so long
do you think Jeff was something going on
in the island this is true maybe too
long you know what I'm saying should
have pulled a plug has anyone ever lived
that long with the disease
before are you saying it might have been
a cover so he can go over to his you
think he was a faker great cover
manowski got of throw him out of the
chair like
lowski uh no I meant like
uh like they were drinking blood and
oh I think I'm more realistic thing
is the guy can actually walk and
he it was all a cover right here let's
take a look it says the main surviv the
mean survival time is 2 to 5 years some
people live 5 years or up to 10 years
it's a horribly tragic disease it's just
so sad my cousin loie passed away from
Al so oh man it's really tough it it's
just it really is but he ended up living
like decades right he that's crazy then
this article from PBS said how did uming
live 55 years with ALS 55 years dude
there's something going on on that
island did anybody ever live that long
though with ALS before people have cons
I see what you're saying I never heard
any until now I'm thinking though you're
connecting the Adrena Chrome yes
uh Factory on the island to his long
survival this dude just stands up when
he's on the
island it's like the Lost Island all the
articles are like how did he no that's
what lost was really about yeah I'm
afraid that's Epstein's Island bro 76 so
like is he got the world record for that
I don't think so I think there's one
other dude he liveed to be
86 congratulations was 70 I believe man
you know he cheated on his wife with his
nurse yeah he's right yeah he got bag
he's a scoundrel he doesn't sound like a
tip to guy I forgive my how how how does
that work his might still work yeah
definitely I don't know right or maybe
she just sits on his face well he wasn't
maybe he wasn't always they can find a
way they can find a way
imagine she's sitting on his face that's
a good way to accidentally kill him do
that do that do that do that he's drown
he's drowning and do that do that
no so this man was participating in
orgies
well he's dead I can't defame you can't
defame a defame a dead person I'm afraid
isn't that interesting Stephen Hawking
was a pet no I'm kidding I won't even
say it it's not funny allegedly he might
have been yeah
very I can't defame a dead person it's a
known fact do
that even his family can't sue me total
immunity yeah girl how do you defame the
dead it's
impossible so that one was pretty
surprising John Luke Brunell I don't
know who that is he killed himself right
in the prison Den well he has a similar
he he W uh apparently was very caught up
in all of this and he was a very
prominent uh boss of a modeling agency
kind of connects to what we were talking
about earlier with uh a yeah he's the
original Austin oh and yeah he um also
uh was UN he unived himself allegedly in
prison while awaiting trial oh where a
lot of powerful people could be exposed
very similar wow kind of thing there's a
lot of conspiracy theories around his as
well real quick not to divert the
conversation but going back to people
that are still alive with ALS someone in
the chat mentioned this guitar player
named Jason Becker um was diagnosed
pretty young he was playing for like
David Le Roth and was with like all
those greats and he got it and it
totally destroyed his career um but he
still makes music with other people with
the um he's making music now to this day
yes that's obviously he can't play but
he has right thing way yes how old is he
Jason I I think he's in his 50s wow yeah
H such a scary sad disease man why come
on people please scientists
please lab scientists people on coats
whatever just come on guys yeah my
cousin Lo had it and it it was it was
really tragic tough
um Jean Luke let's see a message left
for Epstein by one of his employees in
2005 claimed Jean Luke Brunell French
model Scout who died in 2022 oh he's a
recent uh a recent
D yeah it was a waiting trial for child
rward oh oh o had found a teacher who
could give Epstein free
lessons message left for Epstein by one
of his employees claims that Jean Luke
I'd found a teacher for who could give
Epstein free
lessons that sounds like code word it's
code yeah yeah you can
infer he has a teacher for you to teach
how to speak Russian she is two times 8
years old not blonde the message read
lessons are free and you can have your
first today if you call oh my God Jes
W that's upsetting another person
Epstein's inner circle of friends who
becomes a parent
with almost no investigation effort is
Jean Luke Brunell I've seen sexually
traffic Jane do number three to Jean
Luke Brunell many
times that doesn't I mean the guy's a
model Scout doesn't surprise me here's
one no him Chomsky that this is
going to be your favorite wait who's
that this one is
like it's like written for you Ethan h i
there's probably lots of fans of his in
chat but he's oh that's the he's a he's
a linguist that cosplays as a
philosopher well he is a
philosopher he's very he's a philosopher
of little girls apparently let's
see according to documents Epstein
arranged multiple meetings with noome
chsky in two
multiple in 2015 and 2016 during this
time Mr CH he's still alive so he can
answer for this stuff right yeah during
this time chumsky was teaching at MIT a
university where EP had made sign ific
donations the scheduled meeting involved
Gathering of academics and Mr Chomsky
also took a flight on Epstein's private
jet to New York one specific event
included a dinner at Epstein's
townhouse with film director Woody Allen
and his wife Sun ye his wife AKA
stepdaughter yeah great
jeez you're telling me when I saw that I
was like oh Ethan's got to see this one
Epstein and Woody no no he was just
going he was just going for dinner it
was nothing untour it was also Woody on
was
there you could have convinced me until
then
that I don't know he's he's a he's too
extreme for me I'm I'm not a fan of of
gome Chomsky but I can't say that
publicly because people like him or at
least lefties like him you just said it
you just said it on your show yeah
well I'm putting my neck out there but
now the guy's a pedo so it see I
was right the whole
[Laughter]
time well also like not even like he's
he he's done really up like
he's denied genocides of like uh he gets
like mad criticism he he's a total like
communist and in the sense that
like he's a s for Russia and like
that like the worst kind um I think
let's see no Chomsky I can't I mean I
can't defame him if I just read that he
was in a dinner with EP and Woody Allen
I'm sorry no chonky genocide
denial true criticism for not calling
the
uh Bosnian War a genocide he refused to
acknowledge that and for appearing to
deny mulan's report on the existence of
Bosnian concentration
camps oh my God
oh the Taco Bell's
here Taco Bell for the world you
Chomsky the chomp that's right thank you
Chomp on these nuts yeah yes
oh my God got him so good oh man this is
a soggy Taco that's what I've been
telling you dude someone says he's a
tanky I don't I don't like using that
word cuz I don't really know what it
means and it I know that it's pretty
loaded but as I understand it maybe you
probably know what it is Dan a tanky no
chsky is definitely not a tanky are you
sure yes isn't so a tank is like a
communist who like simps for like
authoritarian communist adjacent yes
yeah no chonky is an
anarchist that is very much opposed to
totalitarian government Anarchist that's
embarrassing that is he is a
self-described Anarchist yes that's
literally embarrassing that you would
even say that about yourself that's like
an edgy a lot of tanky a lot of tankies
would agree with you actually so there
you go like you you found some common
ground with the
tankies I didn't want to say that I'm
just saying bro if you only consider
yourself a Anarchist if you're like
15-year-old in your first like uh poai
class your first block in world history
or
something something for me thank you
thank
you hell yeah well cheers everybody
mhm
congratulations people saying he's a
Libertarian too which is probably the
worst thing you can be in the
world it's a Libertarian in the sense
that he hangs out with Woody Allen if
you know what I'm saying I'm reading the
comments people say he you know what I'm
saying two for two there dude people are
saying he approaches
tanky he comes right up to
it he kisses it on the lip
I'm an anarchist grow up dude how old
are
you how old is n chonky to walk around
saying he's a
Anarchist his 9s
right
90 Lane bro he looks like gond someone
someone Anarchist in Middle School 95
years old no rules my parents
that pretty much sums up uh what chsky
believes he
sucks that's the extent of his work shut
up shut up Dad shut up you still pissed
about it he's 90 years old walk talking
around
mhm give her a anyway he was there so I
was right and he's
wrong I've never been in a room with
epin or Woody on so Checkmate gome
Chomsky I never did Checkmate I never
did who's the genius
now um who else we got do that oh yeah
this one's crazy former Israeli Prime
Minister IAD Barack was he one of the
peace guys a Barak aood Barack mhm was
he he was like the peace guy right well
he was murdered right that's no no
that's Rabin oh not that guy see Mark is
like this is the guy came after him
after a couple times
after he was prime minister in the 2000s
I believe yeah so like closer in
chronological time closer to us George W
bush ER according to documents the
former Israeli pre prime minister AUD
Barack was a frequent visitor to
Epstein's upper easts side townhouse
between 2013 and 2017 that's quite Rec
wait is he still alive yeah yeah uh oh
is the one that sometimes you see
commentating now about the okay I know
who he is yeah you've seen
him Barack has acknowledged these
meetings in the past he said that
Epstein often introduced him to
individuals from various Fields like art
culture law human trafficking science
Finance diplomacy and
philanthropy however he never met
Epstein with girls or miners or even
adult women
an improper context or behavior he
says that's a shot gbt answer you went
to his apartment how many times yeah
brother you need something better than
that like I don't think Epstein becomes
dogs with people that don't you know
what I mean like he's not going to hang
out with you 20 times
unless he can be himself you know what I
mean unless you're down yeah unless
you're down to
exctly that S Talk
they got to figure that
out soggy soggy you were just missing it
like no big deal earlier I tried to warn
your brother still tastes good but yeah
I'm enjoying the soft go for the soft
yeah
yeah sorry
everybody it's not my fault it's uh
Gabe's fault it is gab's Fault Bill
Richardson former Democratic governor of
New Mexico and presidential
candidate Jan Maxwell told you to give
massage to Bill Richardson correct
correct oo he got named in the
[Music]
massage that's
rough rough
that people who are named but not
accused of any wrongdoings
includes Leonardo DiCaprio so so far
everybody was
accused everybody we were yeah of or
another did you say no or yes I said no
not not well Michael Jackson right they
said they answered no to the question of
if they had contact with him so
technically not him well most of the
other ones that we he's dead we can't
defame him we also knew knew stuff from
the past about Michael so we don't need
that accusation he did that 100% C
I was there I saw it I've seen video
evidence he was
there
George Lucas why is this burrito so
messy you're not eating mine are you I
do want on are onions in it I'm tasting
onions that's not a supreme is it oh god
oh
no beef I didn't get a beef burrito oh
great I'm eating your weird burrito how
can you not tell you're
EA jerky so excited for it I here's your
this is a mess well just
yeah you got to approach it okay well
than no I don't want that one you don't
want it but I already ate it I don't
want the Supreme that's a whole that's a
whole thing that I don't want to get
into there's all kinds of in there
you can just put it here I'll eat it you
will yeah such a
mess that is a mess you can have one on
mine if you want I won't e all them I'm
good I'm actually good thing we got the
extra Taco yeah genius play
love I got this down to a t um so just
to Circle back to this uh all the people
that we went over um were either accused
directly I guess uh also um
Chomsky wasn't directly accused of
anything other than associating with
Woody Allen which which is bad in of
itself um the other people that I had
listed here are people that came up in
one way or another but it it really was
just for no reason and it's it's
interesting because I feel like the
reporting on this has been kind of
scattered and irresponsible in a lot of
places because they're just talking
about
um about a list like this list of names
and what that list really is is a
shitload of court documents and all
kinds of testimony and depositions
everything all got released at once and
all these people are people whose names
came up somewhere in there but for
example like George Lucas they were
rattling off a bunch of famous people
asking if they ever saw that person uh
uh at Epstein's mansion or whatever and
the answer was no and so you'll see like
George Lucas right and so you'll see
like George Lucas or Leonardo Di Caprio
named in Epstein documents they are
named but literally just in passing and
not with like any accusation associated
with it so the people that I listed off
were just kind of the biggest names that
actually had something kind of Juicy
there um Leonardo's just sad that
Epstein like now is the time for him to
do that back then he was he was a young
man DiCaprio I put in this one about Al
Gore cuz he was another one um he was be
Supreme cuz there's sour cream in it and
a tomato that's that's why I this
actually might be your that's why I
wasn't sure this one seems pretty good
okay hold on but let me see oh my I
can't control my
goo I think this is mine okay it caused
a big
Panic you want to try mine no doesn't
seem like you like yours very much it's
just very messy I don't know what's the
deal it is very messy right you know
what you got to do with these you got to
like squeeze the cuz the beans are like
liquid you got to push it to the top mhm
you oh my god oh my
god um Al
Gore yeah he was another one that was
put in there um you want me to read it
while you're chewing mhm Guffy during
her deposition alleged that she had once
met the former vice president at a
dinner table with quote people around
describing the encounter she said it's a
little hazy what took place I mean we
were going back a long time ago but I do
remember one thing about him I thought
he was a wonderful guy who loved his
wife and then spent the entire time like
there was nothing else around them it
was just those
two so like randomly like sweet in this
like horrific story she was just like oh
yeah Al Gore he was a treasure he was
great that's actually really nice dude
dude Al Gore just caught a random dub
exactly but he didn't because again I've
seen his name is like Al Gore named in
Epstein documents and then you actually
look into it and it's like oh because
that's the thing this uh Epstein this is
his whole Mo was he like hopk knobbed
with all these rich famous people and so
there were a lot of Rich famous people
who met him and associated with him at
one point but didn't necessarily have
anything to do with sex trafficking
stuff so
yeah
absolutely but know chsky did it well
the the Woody Allen con he still alive
though so
yeah yeah careful exactly right he's an
anarchist he probably doesn't believe in
defamation good yeah exactly Nom chonky
he was there I don't know if he did it
I'm just joking when he dies which will
be
soon then I'll know for sure ask me
them I'm not being mean by the way he's
like in his
90s no yeah5 995 yeah and he's still out
here talking
look at him looks like gandal the
de gandal
the Gand the D yeah look at this God
damn it you shall not
pass how do these people live so
long well you know why he's turned into
an actual
gnome adrenochrome absolutely yep zero
room for doubt
mhm when he dies ask me about
it that should be on a
t-shirt ask me about gome Chomsky when
he
dies I kid gome
Chomsky we love gnomes he get it he gets
it Kan so uh I
mean the soft giving charity Scandal was
pretty crazy wasn't it yeah is there any
updates with that because at the time I
remember
people for example asmin gold was like
he's super pissed about it he's he they
were just mentioned in kind of like
passing that to be one of the companies
that worked with them mhm and honestly
if he just said yo my bad we up
and maybe don a little bit they'd be
chilling but instead he took the that to
his heart the worst response of all time
yeah he like got super that one's even
crazi mess here oh is this trash yeah
it's trash thank you so soft
giving you know what the story is
long it's almost
4:30 yeah yeah I'm sorry I was late
though how long we been going we have
been going for 2 hours 20 minutes 22
minutes here let's go to the top of the
show we got all kinds of fun stuff
um for example
Ian has a really interesting anecdote
about a cockroach no it's good it's good
there's no images okay it's not even
about what the Cockroach did okay here's
an
email eBay said to pay $3 million in
fines after employees sent live spiders
and cockroaches to a couple in
Massachusetts what here's the
email I would like to refund I'd like a
refund of my items it arrived late and
you put a cockroach in my package I do
not appreciate how you've treated me I
would like my money back immediately how
do you even believe that you're like no
way that happened and then that's
Ian's email right yes that's my uh this
is my email wait you wrote this yes in
2012 2012 yeah wait
what what did you
buy I Well the description at the top
says it what in my tweet
there wait I got a cockroach from eBay
in 2012 when I bought a spandex Superman
suit for the Man of Steel movie
premiere this is a real email from my
support ticket cockroach was in a tiny
envelope that said enjoy this are you
serious are you serious yeah they're
just sending them out at random enjoy
this smiley face there
was it was an envelope with the smiley
face I I I remember I thought it was a
gift
card because it was so late it was gift
card size little V and it said like
enjoy this it was something like that it
was enjoy this or it was like um you
know hope you get a hope you uh have a
good time it was something like that I
can't remember because I was going to
say could it be that just like that
happened by accident that a coach
cockroach got into that that was a spike
cockroach for sure yeah it was
intentional were you giving him trouble
or something or was it just a
random uh what it
was were you being a were you being a
caran
okay so it's November 1st 2012 I'm
trying to remember yes I think I bought
it for uh Halloween and then the
Superman movie was coming out as well it
had said it would arrive by like October
25th or something and then it didn't
arrive until November
1st uh so I had emailed them and I was
like hey I need this by the 31st I see
it hasn't shipped yet can you guys try
and expedite the shipping I need it
before the 31st and they didn't respond
and then it arrived with a cockroach in
an
envelope is this another prank after AB
I don't know if I can believe you guys
this is uh this is a I wish because I
opened it and I like screamed and I I
didn't know if it was still alive or not
I was it alive no it was it was dead
yeah just a dead conquer envelope who
are these people that who would do
that yeah that's that's that's psychotic
so did you get a refund or not yeah how
they respond to that email uh eBay uh
did refund me for the Superman what yes
all right what did you make of it at the
time well I'm seeing now that I'm the
refund is about
29998 million short you know well more
than
that
uh crazy but yeah I mean I was just
shocked I I I was pretty surprised I
don't know maybe I was karening a little
too hard asking for the shipping it'll
get there when it gets there chill out
yeah forget Halloween so somebody
actually sued them though for something
similar yes and one well no it's I think
it's just happening right now well I'm
curious because that I wonder if you can
join in on the lawsuit that article
seems to say eBay employees so I'm
curious I I think there's distinction
like someone at an actual eBay facility
there's a whole gang of
insect terrorist roach shippers man it
sounds like I he for sure had a statute
of limitation on this
fortunately I have no photos of the I
don't know what I was using that is so
terrifying to me wish you had taken the
photo
um well they at least owe you an apology
did they
apologize well I guess just the refund
and I did wear the suit to the Man of
Steel Premiere which was really insult
to injury cuz the movie was horrible
yeah so you did get the Su I did get the
suit and the refund I got the suit and
the refund you got it all that's a good
deal I guess yeah somebody said we
should read the article what they did is
even worse than the Cockroach all right
let me open
it oh a bizarre story that's so bizarre
very strange I feel traumatized just
hearing about this just the possibility
of something
happening oh the feds are charging
them feds charge eBay over employees who
sent live spiders and Cockroach to
couple Company to pay 3 million online
retailer eBay will pay 3 million and
fines to resolve criminal charges over
harassment campaign R harassment
campaign waged by employees who sent
live spiders cockroaches and other
disturbing items to the home of
Massachusetts couple according to court
papers filed
Thursday the justice department charged
eBay with stalking witness tampering and
obstruction of justice more than 3 years
after the employees it's going on
prosecuted in the extensive scheme to
intimidate David and Ena Steiner the
couple produced an online newsletter
called e-commerce btes that upset eBay
Executives no the executives were doing
this what it upset eBay Executives with
its coverage California headquartered
eBay accepts responsibility for the
employees action and entered into a
deferred prosecution agreement that
could result in the charges against the
company being dismissed if it complies
with certain conditions according to the
US attorney's office in
Massachusetts eBay engaged in absolutely
horrific criminal conduct the company's
employees and contractors involved in
this campaign put the victims through
pure hell in a uh petrifying campaign
aimed at silencing their reporting and
protecting the eBay brand dude the fact
that this was done by Executives is mind
BL
him
uh what other here's the
details Ena
Steiner received harassing and sometimes
threatening Twitter message as well as
dozens of strange emails from a group
like an irritable bowel syndrome patient
support group and the Communist Party of
the United States along with a box of
live spiders and the Cockroaches the
couple had a funeral wreath a bloody pig
mask and a book about surviving the loss
of a spouse show up at the door whoa
their home address was also posted what
the eBay mob dude that's so scary
it's just
eBay it's not that serious is it what
the hell they
continued their home address was also
posted online with announcements
inviting strangers to yard sales and
parties
wow and a statement published on theirs
Thursday the Steiner said eBay's action
had a damaging and permanent impact on
them emotionally psychologically
physically reputationally and
financially also expressed frustration
that more Executives were not charged
what the
um half hour after the article was
published eBay's then CEO Devin w winig
s another top executive message another
message saying if you ever if you are
ever going to take her down now is the
time the CEO was in on this what
what
what the executive sent winig messages
to James B who was eBay's senior
director of Safety and Security so he
sent so this so this is like a um Brave
New World thing where the director of
Safety and Security is the one that uh
intimidates and threatens
people 1984 but yeah what' I say 1984
close enough I think what happened is it
said what what was their name Ena
Steiner yeah I think Ian Slater there
was oh my God cockroach that was that
was you deserve a cut of this my dude
error you do deserve you deserve a bit
of that man ba was among seven former
employees who ultimately pleaded guilty
to charges in the case dude they're
going to jail he was sentenced in 2022
to almost 5 years in prison another
former executive David Harville was sent
to two years damn wow did they get fired
he better out I would assume so
cuz they're loyal they're loyal good
employees
dude These Are Made Men
yeah well the CEO had a lot to gain or
lose well it sounds like he uh Sid
stepped the criminal charges somehow W
egg who stepped down as CEO in 2019 was
not criminally charged in the case and
has denied having any knowledge of the
harassment throw him under the bus or
ever telling anyone to do anything
illegal in the civil cases lawyers have
said that the quote take her down quote
was taken out of context and the natural
inference should be that he was
referring to taking lawful action not a
series of bizarre criminal
acts they got to get him on the RICO
absolutely this is a up this is
crazy bro eBay what is happening on eBay
W just anyone use eBay or you use eBay
you're like the only person I know that
does I occasionally will get stuff off E
I used to but but I kind of stopped
actually I'm boycotting eBay what did I
I just got something from e but
generally um I haven't heard this stuff
before and I think people like eBay not
anymore are they traded publicly I
wonder if this should let's see eBay
stock price eBay was the only place I
could find another cursed Cosby doll we
need go all right I guess specialty
items sometimes when you need eBay you
need eBay lot of signed calling bger
head
shot Craig Miss can you forward me those
links when did the Scandal uh
break it kinded like it was in like 2019
2020 is so was that this or was that Co
was Co in
2020 2020 yes are you serious that was
so long ago serious crazy right yes sir
2020 God
me and the lockdowns started in like
March 2020 I want to say God damn it's
correct God damn cuz I didn't get to go
back after spring
break damn Yeah March 15 2020 lock down
here's a post from history memes okay
guys this is important I was today years
old when I learned Nome Chomsky is a
genocide denier he's got a he's playing
uh Uno acknowledge the Bosnian genocide
or Draw 25 cards this is such a weirdly
specific it has 2,000 points where did
you just dig this up I just because I
was still open when I searched gome
chsky genocide
[Music]
deny was hyp specific this is just a
history meme
so okay elaborate the top common is wow
he doesn't need to there's 2,000 points
on
it says it all get on mem says it
all yeah a good
sucks um another thing I want to talk
about
so everybody knows George Carlin people
consider him to be one of the best
stand-ups
ever um he's dead he's been dead for a
while somebody made a full special
written and produced by
Ai and I watched
supposedly there is some reason to maybe
doubt that a little bit which you'll
see well I watched the whole thing did
you really yeah got through that the
jokes were not bad and it was super
tightly written like it was pretty good
it was not fishy or weird and it was
like super topical it was it was really
good I it I'll say it I thought it
was good it's crazy does this get
claimed I did not oh great so I can show
you guys an example he actually he had a
great um section about trans people that
was so George Carlin and so like against
what you would expect from from
comedians today um I'm telling you
here's one about mass shootings he
starts talking about as good car crashes
train crashes plane crashes sex drugs in
the common cold all for the express
purpose of killing you no matter where
you are in the world God can pull out
one of these goodies from his bag of
tricks to end your life at any time for
no reason other than he just gets off on
making people suffer unnecessarily and
die
arbitrarily that's this is the god
section but if you're in America you're
special God made something just for you
something no other country on the planet
gets it's totally random not related to
your diet exercise lifestyle age race
gender sexuality or genetic
predisposition of course I'm talking
about mass
shootings
other countries are fine killing one
person at a time with guns but this is
America where we do things bigger and
better and more
often there are so many mass shootings
in America it's replaced bad traffic as
the number one excuse for being late he
was like sorry I missed the morning
meeting a maniac with an AR-15 shot up
my son's preschool he's fine just grazed
but he did see five of his classmates
get gunned down in Cold Blood so I'm
sure he'll be traumatized for the rest
of his life in ways I can never fully
understand anyway what do we decide to
do about the budget next
quarter there's a mass shooting every 20
hours in America and it doesn't seem
like anyone is going to do anything
about it other countries don't have this
problem at all look at Japan 127 million
people last year seven were killed by
gun seven no mass shootings at all you
know what they do if a Japanese person
wants to buy a gun they have to attend
an all day class pass a written test and
Achieve at least 95% accuracy on a
shooting range and then they have to
pass a mental health evaluation which
takes place at a hospital and then they
have to pass a government background
check that includes interviews with
their friends family and co-workers
hello sir did you know that Bob in
accounting wants to buy a gun no I
didn't know
that do you think we should let Bob by a
gun well he did just go through a nasty
divorce and yesterday he told me he
hates this job so much he wishes he
could kill everybody in the building so
maybe not right now I think this sucks
this is hor disturbing this is
literally his comedy this is disturbing
and wrong well this is literally it's
literally not it's okay DN it literally
is not I don't know what I I'm telling
you this is crazy good for what it
is being a robot I'm impressed dude he
he he captures the the Cadence and the
delivery and like even even the subject
matter I wish they the the video element
cuz that part is weird so I
think it's all AI yeah right I know I'm
I'm saying we didn't need the video I
agree the video is the worst part about
the the thing maybe if I was more
familiar with him I would find it
funnier but I mean it's not his this is
his his style it's like I do feel like
it captures the essence of his style
here I'm trying to find from what I know
I'm not I don't know a lot of his comedy
but things I've seen I enjoy the
pictures it did yeah was nice to watch
seems
like that would hate this the most
absolutely yeah it's be that as it
may his da crazy good his daughter spoke
out against it she said it's ghoulish
and creepy okay so it then I mean
it's got to be this has to be
IP
violation still the technology is insane
just I'm telling you it's it's wild wild
and I turn this on expecting be like
this is just weird and awful I watched
the whole thing you want to do
the the Trans America one about trans
people stop me if you guys want to sink
in let's get back to conservatives
hating trans people for no reason some
of the arguments they use to justify
their transphobia seem like a bit of a
stretch to me well I don't want a man to
be able to walk into a women's restroom
and see my wife naked first of all what
in the is your wife doing naked in
a public
[Music]
bathroom and second of all if you really
think there is a significant number of
guys who want to watch your wife take a
you should start an only fans
immediately and by the way for anyone
who thinks Jesus cares cares about which
bathroom somebody uses he was
in a hole he dug with his own
hands just like everybody else 2,000
years
ago the Wright likes to bring up that
kids are too young to know if they trans
or gay so they have to ban any books
that talk about gender identity or
sexuality from the school libraries
that's how you're going to save the
children by taking books out of a
library hey you can take the
whole Library we have the
internet
now and they love talking about how
small the trans Community is they say
trans people make up such a small
percentage of the population that they
shouldn't get to have any input in
legislation even laws that will directly
affect their communities and lives funny
how that same argument doesn't apply to
members of the
[Music]
NRA but I have to admit the one point
they really hang their hat on is one
that the rest of the country is still
undecided on too Sports everybody saw
the video of the high school volleyball
player who got her nose broken by a
trans player spiking the ball everybody
knows about Leah Thomas winning a
division one swimming title it's hard
for most people to watch her highlight
reel and not at least wonder if maybe
she had a little bit of an unfair
advantage and once that thought is out
there in the American Town Square it's
hard to get rid of but I think there's a
way because for every superstar like
Leah Thomas there are a thousand trans
athletes who are absolutely
mediocre and there are even more who are
[Music]
terrible just like it is with CIS
athletes not everyone can be great I
think all we need to do to change hearts
and Minds is start making compilation
videos of trans athletes performing
miserably in their chosen
Sports
all it would take is one video of a
transcender getting dunked on to go
viral and then everybody could unpucker
their about the issue and move
on to other
things and I just want to preface what
I'm going to say next by explaining that
I mean no offense to the incredible
swimmers of the world your
accomplishments and dedication are truly
inspirational but it's
swimming the world is teetering closer
and closer to the edge of World War II
on a daily basis and the American public
is debating who can and can't compete in
recreational
floating you almost had another civil
war for sake 2,000 people stormed
the United States capital building with
the goal of murdering
politicians actually when I put it like
that it doesn't sound so
bad the point is the land of the free
and the home of the brave is hanging on
by a thread and people's most pressing
concern is whose picture is on a can of
Bud
Light this does not bode well for the
Great American
[Music]
experiment but it's not entirely your
fault it's like I said earlier the
billionaires want it this way it's not
bad it's a I mean you know as far it's a
bit about trans people that isn't super
bigoted and crazy yeah I have a question
why I thought it was good I thought it
was good why can't AI spell stuff in the
photos it's a good question like it's so
smart even looking at look at the TV
it's all Target and then s up S
selling kids co
co it's getting there though that's
pretty impressive comparison how it was
seems like that part would be easy
doesn't it the
spelling oh Ian says we should have
them do an H3 podcast oh no I don't want
them coming for my job
[Music]
um I'd be down if there look at ducky
he's just drinking he won't get out of
his bed
a
puppy I was I was super impressed I
don't know what to tell y'all no
technolog is definitely I'm impress yeah
I'm not really arguing about the
technology being impressive or not I
just think it's uh horrific and
dystopian as it is horrific yeah
but the jokes were not bad that's they
were like pretty good okay so so here's
the thing this dudes Le account this is
a this is a you know who Will Sasso is
Matt TV guy yes yeah so this is him and
another guy by the name of Chad I am
still they uploaded on a
comedy yeah and uh yeah they made this
and uh a lot of people have wondered
it's probably not they they probably
punched this up quite a bit this was I
assume there was some human interven
mention right you know I don't know how
much maybe they wrote the whole thing
you know and just had George Carlin's
voice to
it um have they talked about
it not that I'm aware of maybe let's go
to their Twitter account and see if they
said anything about it I feel like it
could be AI just thinking about what
Chad gbt can do well chat if you ask
Chad to write jokes they're not good
they're like up like this is like
complex social issues I feel like if you
prompted it correctly you could make sh
chat GPT do that maybe maybe not I don't
know let's see Twitter where the is
Twitter they off that too
eh Legends they're off Twitter we love
that about
them yeah I don't I don't think there's
anything about it but yeah I didn't know
that it was posted
by
comedians well either way it's what it
is somebody said it's aidus n out of 10
I sent their Twitter you
did let's see if they said anything
about
it AI podcast YouTube
show a
um yeah nothing about it I
think they post a whole podcast uh
reacting to it was was actually kind of
strange cuz they were like kind of
acting like they didn't make it even
though it's on their Channel well if if
they did it via AI maybe they never
heard it before
and there it is all right well that's
all I have to say about that
congratulations can we please talk about
Cat Williams I'm just glad that bro
everybody's thinking it that like Joe
Rogan and all of his friends just suck
like it's like people are starting to
understand he had such a funny line
about Joe he goes uh Joe Rogan doesn't
want me on his podcast he's been pushing
out six commedians that never been
funny it's funny when he says it of
course but you guys know how I feel
about the Rogan knites yeah we say you
know in the comedy world we say we're
the last line of defense sure are
buddy um what was I typing oh yeah the
Cat Williams thing dude I have never
seen people are saying their show is
like ran by AI it's Cutting Edge
technology oh their so it's not them in
it I that's what some people I think
we're missing something I think yeah
yeah um anyway this has 45 million views
after nine days like
bananas yeah
wow I mean I know what you say about it
I I'm got nothing to do with me I'm
happy to say although yeah because he
was just eviscerating everybody
man you know what do you want me to say
about
it I've always liked Cat Williams he's
funny as and I was it was
fascinated when he had like this insane
Fall From Grace when he got in a fight
with the high school kid and it was
filmed to his ass getting beat by a high
school kid you remember that that rings
a bell I kind forgot about that Cat
Williams fighting a high school kid and
it was just like
whoa
Cat Williams sucker punches a kid and
gets his ass beat what yep Jesus swear
to God wait you probably can't show te's
friends so the show they like no but
it's not super
violent um fighting with a child I think
he's let's just say he's 18 I don't
know
literally oh he's in seventh grade how
old would that make him seventh grade
seventh grade is like seventh grade is
like 133 that's like when I went to
Neverland
seventh grade is like
12 12 years old hold on let me just
watch a second of
it that's an adult maybe he is actually
said okay he's fighting this
dude all right so I'm just going to fast
forward then just so you guys show how
it ends with him getting like his ass
he's in like a head choke I mean this is
really he look at this he's getting
choked out by a child oh my
God what this was from
2016 but actually surprisingly he's back
like he's he's on top of the game again
he's selling out tours he's got comedy
specials I thought he was done when I
saw this is Rock Bottom there's only up
from
here crazy
right what how do you just roll up on
school and get no fight with the kid
even yeah all right
wow I'm so confused how that has 45 mil
mhm who I don't even know who this guy
is I've been he's very famous he's very
famous comedian but still that's so many
views he was he went on and was just
dogging on like the most famous people
in comedy and then he was what he was
saying was so severe and people were
loving it so much that the people he was
talking about all were forced to respond
which made it even bigger ice cube made
a response video Joe Rogan responded to
it um Cedric I think respond like people
were he talked on Steve Harvey who
said something about it dude he was
going off Rogan responded as well I did
say that oh sorry I was listening to the
video yeah we both said it well I I sent
the video though if you didn't want to
show it of him going going off of him
talking about Joe Rogan what you were
talking about okay yeah oh thank you
perfect Joe don't want me on there I
need to be on Shannon Joe Joe got six
comedians that never been funny he want
to push
out now Joe Ren reacted to this saying I
love cat he's one of my okay
thanks yeah he just tweeted at him a
decent response you
know definitely watch it though it's
pretty crazy especially the first like
minutes sucker punching a kid and then
getting beat up is a l forever I thought
so
too yeah it seemed like that's the end
of I didn't know how you come back from
that yeah how do you come back from
that
[Music]
uh it's uh five o'clock just so you know
we're back our week is we're first week
back mhm we are back it's happen
happening thank you everybody for
watching it's been a great week of
shows next week we are planning some fun
silly goofy hilarious things absolutely
it's going to be a wild wild wild week
will not want to miss in the meantime
every also can I make a small uh
programming note or whatever something
I've been uh seeing in the comments a
lot is uh what happened to the uniform
idea we had voted on a uniforms it's
coming they're in the works um maybe is
early as next week I guess we'll see it
it's a delicate process we don't want to
do it bad
so it's going to also Sam's not here
this week and one I have reason I have
two Notes too just for chat listen you
see you bastards you see this what's
this this is my my job is to watch stuff
and I when I click this I can only hear
what's coming through when I'm watching
something on my laptop and then when I
go back I go back to the show so that's
why sometimes I repeat something Ethan
said also my second notations BTS after
Today's Show You bastards there'll be a
BTS after today show about our live show
behind the scen so that'll be a great
one for members right for members yes
for members I watched it made me very
happy nice very good in fact uh it's
upload unlisted should I just should I
uh publish on this right now yeah
all right for members uh the BTS is
going up congratul and then another
thing Dan what about your
chair uh so that so I do have
a new relatively decent Prospect with
that I I found somebody that wants to
take it on um we have to talk specifics
and cost and everything um cuz I've been
down this route twice already now um and
they got scared off both times it just
like seemed like nobody wanted wanted
the smoke from uh from the Enterprise or
something but um but I have somebody who
uh express interest in stepping up and
so um it it's it's it's still in the
works what was the first quote we got
price-wise it was like 25 Grand so I was
I said I was willing to spend anything
but I think me and Dan were both like I
no yeah to Ethan's credit he was like
should we do it I was like I can't make
you spend
$225,000 stupid I made a
pledge but 25 is that's a stupid stupid
amount for the second place I talked to
was a little bit they were still
expensive but it was a lot less than 25
Grand um but yeah they got like they
they stopped responding to my emails
they like bounced on me I think they got
scared
because we're basically infringing on IP
well somewhat I mean you know it's a
love letter I don't think it's it
depends it depends how it's I mean if we
were making a
uh a a Sci-Fi show and we're like using
that I don't know it's parody it's
parody I think I think it's fine I think
it's fine
but yeah um but yeah they were somebody
you're right they were somebody that
works professionally in the prop making
industry in LA and they may not have
wanted right to sour any relationships
with Studios um so that's a work in
progress uh what I keep getting two
questions today what is my lip gloss so
it's people really want to know it's
this Dior lip glow oil
cherry and what is the hat is my friend
her brand is called BP Bella
really cute stuff so check it out love
that hat check it out um also another
question that we get a lot uh is what
happened to the bbtv uh vacation it's
just become it basically became
impossible to coordinate a baby happened
the baby Dan Oliver little Oliver yeah
it's not the baby not the baby well it's
not the baby it's everything it's just
it's so hard to coordinate with
everybody and find a place that
everybody so we're just going to do
another Vegas trip but we're goingon to
do it big oh sh we're gonna do it big
we're gonna do it big I told you
I want to do all the stupid let's
put like yes all the stupid want race
Lambos I want to race you in a Lambo or
whatever that's the one thing I'd rather
do the flying I want to do all the
stupid you rather do the what I'm
telling you the driving thing sucks you
go out it's like far out of town you sit
there and they're like you have to do
like a tutorial that's so dumb and they
talk to you like a child you feel so you
feel stupid you know what I'm talking
about let the kids okay let the kids do
it I'll sit back
watch all right just let me rip the
Lambo dog I'll pay for it and
you guys can go that's what yeah you're
paying for it bbtv is paying for it well
it's my money btv's money the money
thatb let's buy a company Lamborghini
instead wait you were saying something
about flying though yeah we'll fly they
have that here too what what you're
talking about when you go into a tunnel
and like the air pushes you up oh I it's
called I here fly there but yeah let
let's do that please that I've always
wanted to try I wonder if my Apex of
fatness if I could even float 100% 100%
they'll take you all the way to the top
gasket on the fan dude have you done it
before people used to do it for their
birthday parties growing up it's at
unival that's fun is it awesome it's so
fun they a guy does it with you and so
he'll hold you and he takes you like up
to the Top If you want he'll like turn
you around it's super
fun but um well not going to be able to
do anything
cuz I'm pregnant right you you
probably Al even in the casino floor
it's so like Smoky
M this is what I meant by let's cancel
the
trip well after the baby's here I mean
it's not that far away we can really go
yeah but then you're going to have a
newborn he can't be in there we can find
a weekend I mean if we're just going
away for a weekend I think we can my mom
mhm it's normal all right well we'll
figure it out we don't have to figur it
out right this because once you give
birth then we can really go nutty yeah
the baby might like the slots yeah what
if the baby wants
to start young
days just put him in front of the
machine just make him baby for a bit I
don't think the baby wants second Head
smoke for like 72 hours that's true just
walking around you smells the cigarette
second hand smoking isn't real come on
guys I question
it all right when maybe when after the
baby like a month after or something
then we can go bananas well at that
point we're kind of talking about our
June break it seems like oh my God
always K down forever this is what keeps
happening here we can race the
Lambos let's go uh let's race some
NASCARs let's go like 250 mil an hour
dude and then here's another thing when
we shot our video at this the exotic car
thing the dude was like oh yes somebody
died here last year when they drove off
the road and the good thing that's a
good thing you know real yeah that he's
like yeah that him and the instructor
both died good probably a
dumbass MH I was like what yeah I'm not
trying to look like Jay Leno flipping in
a car I'll take that money and go to the
casino that's what I want to do that was
fun last time just Blackjack all day oh
yeah I'll put a lot of money down for
everybody I was going to say it's a lot
of fun gambling with you it is I I'm
giving my money to love and sending him
to well last time I was there I probably
went down to C five times but I was
sitting next to Ethan and he just kept
juicing me oh yeah did you end up up
yeah like 500 bucks that was awesome but
I definitely went to zero five times
before that all right maybe I'm we got
you back though we got you back yeah
yeah dog oh everyone's saying I'm
wearing a Whopper shirt I don't this is
I haven't eaten a Whopper in years
Whopper colors yeah I have no idea
Whopper doesn't many oh wait a minute I
kind of see it it is yeah a little bit
hold on Whopper left it's just Burger
King in general Burger wrapper but
they're saying cuz like each one is like
a layer on a burger no it's just a c
that's how I'm saying this is a new
thing I've never even seen this there
you go oh interesting l mean the rapper
wait hold on who eats that Burger King
what's wrong with you I to this day I
don't
know is that what you guys are talking
about I sent you I sent you picture of
what they're talking about I think wa
what the they wear this yeah of
course they do that's sick Bro
what I have never seen these guys they
make them wear these hoodies the last
time you've been in a Burger King never
that's why
probably last time I was in a burger
probably 30 years 30 years ago huh yeah
30 years know your way around some meat
Burger King was the first American kind
of restaurant that comes to Sweden
except McDonald's and it was such a
disappointment
there's already a
sub in Israel we have like McDonald's
and Burger King wait what the sucks
it really
sucks it's a Whopper the only difference
is that there's like orange and yeah
somebody said I thought it was blue and
yellow that's what I remember for Burger
King blue and yellow Whopper when they
do this I guess it's Burger
colors so is this burger like a new
branding this isn't Brown this is purple
okay
okay this is purple mhm this is
pink that could be the meat and these
two guns are looking for trouble we got
some ketchup in there lettuce oh no the
red is the Tomato slice yeah and the
other ones the onion yeah I see it all
right we'll order a Whopper shirt and
we'll include some uh maybe dead onions
maybe maybe they will sponsor us yeah
I'll eat it sa I'll take it all right
guys thank you everyone for watching
back on Monday have a great weekend
everybody until then this has been the
H3 podcast
[Music]
t